si tout le monde veut bien s'installer
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
bien entendu c'est avec plaisir monsieur
le ministre nous accueillons à nouveau
dans cette audition je crois que c'est
la quatrième puisqu'on s'était vu en
juillet on s'était vu pour le PLV 23
c'était pour le l'exportation des
armements et donc nous sommes là pour la
4e audition audition publique et depuis
votre dernier édition nous avons réalisé
trois cycles thématiques donc le budget
2023 j'en parlais à l'automne le retour
d'expérience sur la guerre en Ukraine et
nous avons une audition en cours sur la
un cycle d'audition encore sur la
dissuasion dont nous terminerons dans
une quinzaine de jours les auditions et
d'ailleurs c'est dans ce cas de ce cycle
d'audition qui a commission s'est rendu
la semaine dernière à Brest pour visiter
la base de l'île Longue et je remercie
notre collègue Jean-Charles larseneur
qui a d'ailleurs organisé une réunion
publique la deuxième de la commission
qui a rassemblé plus de 150 personnes
j'en profite pour lui souhaiter un très
bon anniversaire Jean-Charles 39 ans
aujourd'hui si j'ai bien noté
et finalement je le disais c'était la
troisième réunion publique puisque nous
étions à Pau chez José puyauto avec les
Terriens avec les marins chez
Jean-Charles les prochainement nous
serons en Dordogne avec Jean-Pierre cuir
taffon et les gendarmes de Saint-Astier
notamment pour continuer ce cycle de
réunion au public
monsieur le ministreur TV aux armées
vendredi dernier sur la base aérienne de
Mont-de-Marsan le président de la
République a présenté le cadre général
de ce que sera la future loi de
programmation militaire 2024 2030 il a
également précisé l'enveloppe de 413
milliards d'euros dans la précisé des
grandes orientations vous le savez la
commission de la défense est déjà au
travail sur cette loi de programmation
militaire bien entendu au-delà de nos
auditions nous avons participé plus
activement possible au groupe de travail
que vous avez impulsé nous en avons
constitué nous-mêmes nous avons lancé
cinq missions d'information autour
d'expérience de la actuelle LPM la
préparation opérationnelle les fonds
marins la défense seul r les stocks de
munitions qui rendront d'ailleurs leurs
travaux d'ici mi-février
avant de vous laisser la parole monsieur
le ministre je précise également que
nous aurons l'occasion de vous
auditionner à nouveau prochainement et
plus spécifiquement concernant notre
aide militaire à l'Ukraine
de vous adresser tous mes vœux pour
cette année 2023 j'ai l'occasion de vous
l'écrire mais évidemment je le fais
désormais de manière collégiale et
publique des vœux évidemment pour la
Commission le Parlement qui va devoir
évidemment examiner vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président c'est votre
programme militaire dans un moment
difficile sur lequel on sait qu'on est
observé observé par nos compétiteurs on
l'oublie mais enfin ils observent très
presque que nous faisons et revenir
observer évidemment par nos alliés
observés par notre armée par nos
populations et donc merci évidemment du
du travail qui est accompli ici puisque
au fond si la Cinquième République a
organisé les choses d'une telle manière
dans la réalisation des forces armées
dans la relation que le Président de la
République a comme chef des armées il
faut le redire le Parlement a une place
importante dans le contrôle du
gouvernement sur ce qui est mis en
oeuvre que cela soit sur le fond comme
sur aussi la forme l'organique comme on
dit si bien et donc moi je redis ma
disponibilité pour pour la commission
pour le Parlement y compris sur la forme
si vous tentez quelques innovations de
questions-réponses je tenterai de de me
hisser à ce à ce niveau en tout cas
attendu par la présidence de cette
commission peut-être parce que j'ai
compris que on va essayer de faire un
peu le bilan de la construction de la
LPM revenir sur le discours du président
de la République peut-être aussi vous
détailler puisque je n'ai pas encore
pris la parole publiquement sur
qu'est-ce qui va se passer entre
maintenant et le dépôt du texte en
conseil des ministres parce que autant
qu'il y a des grands principes qui ont
été arrêtés par le chef de l'État un
cadrage budgétaire j'imagine qu'on y
reviendra enfin l'arrêter c'est que la
copine n'est pas complètement terminée
programmation militaire c'est une courbe
avec une trajectoire j'entends c'est du
normatif c'est un rapport dit annexe qui
permet aussi de fixer le nouveau
référentiel opérationnel qui permet de
décliner différents contrats
opérationnels qui permettent décliner
évidemment le tableau avec les cibles
capacitaires donc il reste encore quand
même quelques quelques semaines de
travail et j'y reviendrai effectivement
j'ai donné un mandat à DGA sur un la
capacité parce qu'au fond quand même
c'est ce qui structure aussi le rythme
d'exécution de la programmation
militaire pas que et puis évidemment
faudra revenir aussi sur les attendus
opérationnels que que nous souhaitons en
tout cas
nous espérons pouvoir répondre dans les
dans les temps qui viendront j'aimerais
d'abord revenir quand même sur la
méthode je suis mise armée depuis 8 mois
je vois bien que je suis arrivé et
j'étais nommé dans une maison qui au
fond bien que la loi de programmation
militaire actuelle était exécutée à
l'euro près bien que les crédits est
augmenté une maison qui est encore au
fond à ces traumatisée par les
diminutions de crédit parfois exécuté
sous forme d'une RGPP un peu aveugle qui
a parfois des capitaines un certain
nombre de programmes et au fond on a on
a encore dans le fond même des âmes des
armées de celles et ceux qui ont à
connaître des éléments de gestion il y a
encore cette cette stratégie parfois du
hérisson dans lequel on cherche à se
protéger et au fond évidemment c'est pas
complètement le même grammaire et la
même philosophie qu'il faut employer
quand les crédits augmentent et
singulièrement lorsqu'ils augmentent de
manière importante donc j'ai ressenti ça
assez vite et au fond je vois bien que
la machine avait pour habitude
d'attendre la courbe souvent une courbe
qui diminuait parfois qui augmentait et
d'ailleurs on ne le dit pas assez
président mais si l'autre programmation
militaire actuel augmente les crédits au
fond c'est quand même la première année
à la qu'une marche à 3 milliards et on
va voir et vous le voyez déjà dans les
visites sur les bases aériennes les
régiments ou base navale au fond que le
caractère un peu perceptible des efforts
de LPM actuel se faire jour au final
seulement maintenant à certains égards
c'est pas vrai de tout bien sûr mais en
tout cas sur beaucoup d'aspects le
caractère visible de ces efforts vont se
faire sentir maintenant et en tout cas
tout ça pour dire que aller chercher la
courbe était un peu la posture et en
fonction de la courbe on essayait de
faire un format d'armée dans lequel on
n'abîmait pas trop les choses on
remettait pas en question un modèle
d'armée dit complet on essayait de
d'étaler tant bien que mal les
différents programmes pour faire en
sorte que ça rentre dans la trajectoire
c'est pas une critique mais c'est
malheureusement ce qui s'est passé
singulièrement ces dernières années et
d'ailleurs il y a eu plusieurs lois de
programmation militaires dans l'histoire
souvent de notre programmation militaire
qui ont amplifié et soutenu l'effort
décider dans les années 60 c'est
particulièrement vrai des LPM entre 1970
et le début des années 90 au moment où
la dissolution du Pacte de Varsovie nous
fait rentrer dans une autre perspective
il y a les LPM années 90 est suivant qui
tire les conclusions de la dissolution
du pack de Varsovie mais aussi de
l'émergence d'un terrorisme militarisé
avec tout ce que l'on connaît ensuite et
puis c'était le PM au fond qui est un
peu particulière celle qui se termine
d'HYD réparation parce qu'au final au
moment où on commençait à attaquer le
dur du modèle d'armée faut pas se
raconter d'histoires cette loi a permis
de redonner un peu d'oxygène et celle
que nous allons
construire en tout cas ensemble je
l'espère et vous proposer prochainement
au fond elle s'inscrit dans une autre
logique et celle précisément que les
gaullistes en tout cas sur une méthode
que l’égoïste ont employé dans les
années 60 c'est de se dire au fond le
monde va très très vite les menaces
changent regardons avec lucidité le
diagnostic sécuritaire qui plane
au-dessus de la nation française et en
fonction de ce diagnostic posons en
intimité la question à notre appareil
militaire de se dire qu'est-ce qu'on est
capable de couvrir comme risque
qu'est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
couvrir comme risque qu'est-ce qu'on est
capable de faire seul qu'est-ce que l'on
doit faire à plusieurs qu'est-ce que
l'on peut faire à plusieurs qu'est-ce
que l'on doit faire seul autant de
sujets sur lequel nous sommes évidemment
revenus très longuement avec le séma les
chefs d'état-major d'armée et bien sûr
aussi la DGA la DGS ou le DGSE ces
dernières semaines bon ce travail
d'introspection interne il est assez
inédit je n'ignore pas que certains
auraient encore aimé un livre blanc moi
vous le savez je suis prudent sur
l'outil du Livre Blanc parce que jusqu'à
preuve du contraire il a permis de
maquiller des diminutions budgétaires
c'est ainsi et ensuite souvent il était
aussi fait pour gagner du temps pour un
nouveau président de la République élu
qui comme ça pouvait prendre 12 à 18
mois pour essayer de trouver quelques
points de repère stratégique quand y
compris quand parfois des majorités au
Parlement étaient parfois pas toujours
bien alignés sur des sujets un peu
sensibles comme notamment la question de
l'OTAN ou la dissuasion nucléaire bon
nous on n'est pas dans la même situation
car en Ukraine reconduction du mandat
présidentiel une LPM qui a commencé à
réparer les choses et puis une volonté
d'augmenter les moyens des armées donc
on a fonctionné un peu différemment donc
ça évidemment moi je pense que c'est clé
dans la manière dont vous allez
comprendre aussi le programmation
militaire et vous allez la travailler
vous allez l'amender vous allez sûrement
d'ailleurs là pour certains la critiquer
c'est bien heureux démocratiquement ce
qu'il faut en revanche évidemment c'est
jamais de perte de vue à quel risque
sécuritaire veut-on répondre si j'avance
un peu sur ce sujet la réalité que plus
que jamais il nous faut garder au fond
un modèle d'armée complet mais pas comme
avant
si je vais commencer par là complet mais
pas comme avant parce que on aura
toujours un besoin impérieux de lutter
contre le terrorisme avec les capacités
qui vont avec pour y revenir on voit
bien qu'on a plus que jamais besoin
d'une dissuasion nucléaire robuste et
crédible pour reprendre la formule
consacrée dans un moment on a une guerre
conventionnelle aux portes de l'Europe
sousoutenue claire et dans un moment où
plus personne n'en parle beaucoup je me
suis permis de le faire en répondant à
la question du député royaume tout à
l'heure on a aussi de nouveau de la
prolifération particulièrement
inquiétante sur des armes de destruction
massive avec des doctrines d'emploi plus
que flou potentiellement de pays qui
veulent remettre en cause un ordre
établi en tout cas on pourra là aussi y
revenir sur les questions de
prolifération qui sont évidemment clés
et puis à ces menaces là on voit bien
qu'on a des nouvelles menaces qui
viennent s'additionner j'ai dit si on
avait des menaces qui pouvaient rentrer
des menaces précédentes ou à moindrir
des menaces différentes là on a une pure
addition géologique quelque sorte de ces
risques là le risque climatique parce
que nos AR on a déjà parlé en séance
budgétaire mais peuvent avoir vocation
évidemment à répondre à des enjeux et
des difficultés climatiques en y
reviendra avec une copie particulière
autour de l'outre-mer parce qu'on sait
très bien que dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer les forces armées peuvent
être les premières à marcher sur des
difficultés importantes l'outre-mer
toujours sur des contestations de
souveraineté l'outre-mer fait partie de
la nation française nous intérêts vitaux
enfin on le voit bien aussi qu'on peut
les menaces dites hybrides peuvent
trouver parfois un terrain beaucoup plus
perméable dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et singulièrement dans la
dopécifique parce que le Pacifique Nord
va devenir une zone de tension on le
sait et que par définition en point de
contact les territoires ultramarins qui
sont dans le Pacifique Sud peuvent
connaître par ricochet certaines de ses
secousses y compris d'ailleurs aussi
parce que la pêche illégale parce que
les différents trafics en tout genre
peuvent aussi venir pour en mettre en
cause certains modèles de souveraineté
dans nos autres territoriales ou nos
zones économiques exclusives en tout cas
et donc il faudra évidemment aussi le
réaffirmer donc on a cette addition et
puis en plus on a des espaces nouveaux
pareil sur le cyber quand on voit bien
que le champ de bataille conventionnel
devient électronique et devient lisible
qu'il est parfois
ubérisable on y reviendra aussi c'est un
des rétextes importants autour
d'expérience important de l'Ukraine bon
on voit bien aussi comment nos
infrastructures civiles peuvent faire
l'objet d'attaquer hybride à des fins
militaires alors après aussi des
questions doctrine qu'il faudra
d'ailleurs qu'on imagine dans commission
monsieur le Président c'est qu'est-ce
qu'il doit reposer sur les armées
qu'est-ce qui relève aussi d'une
protection et d'une défense cyber plus
globale qui repose sur chaque
institution entre prise association
collectivités locales à quel moment
on regarde aussi la notion de frontière
sur évidemment les attaques cyber donc
là je sais qu'un certain nombre de
questions je suis pas trop long on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais il est
clair que la LPM si elle ne traite pas
le spatial ou le cyber et je rajouterais
un troisième volet les fonds sous marins
on passe à côté de quelque chose bon
alors il y a des sujets sur lequel on
est plutôt en avance l'argent qu'on va
mettre sur la table va nous permettre de
garder cette avance et d'accélérer et
des sujets sur le cas on est en retard
évidemment j'aurais à vous présenter une
stratégie spécifique sur les drones
puisqu'on sait très bien qu'on a pris en
retard qui a mes yeux n'est pas
acceptable ces années précédentes
les responsabilités compris pour
moi-même et donc de fait maintenant le
sujet c'est pas de rattraper le retard
on n'a pas de sens le sujet c'est
désormais de se débrouiller d'être en
avance sur certains segments pour les
drones dans les années qui viennent
aussi encore à notre exemple je pourrais
encore en donner beaucoup d'autres
peut-être encore un dernier sur la
défense solaire dont on voit bien
qu'elle soutient et compris notre
dissuasion nucléaire on voit bien aussi
que elle présente un intérêt majeur pour
les grands événements comme les Jeux
Olympiques qui nous attendent qu'elle
présente aussi un intérêt majeur je le
disais il y a quelques instants pour
sécuriser nos territoires d'outre-mer
que on voit bien que pour l'ensemble de
l'Europe la protection du ciel on peut
sur défensive sera toujours un sujet
d'actualité et même pour demain les
Ukrainiens qui ont à connaître de ce
sujet dans le conflit terrible qu'ils
connaissent même en 4p
[Musique]
413 400 413 milliards en espèces qui a
été présenté vendredi par le Président
de la République donc quand on commence
à aller reprendre par morceau par
fonction tout d'un coup on s'aperçoit
qu'on retombe sur des sommes sur des
paquets à 5 ou 10 milliards d'euros par
fonction et évidemment ça va très très
vite je ne veux pas qu'on oublie dans
cet LPM ce qu'on appelle réparation en
fait des choses qu'il faudra sans cesse
réparer tous ceux qui ont été maires ou
présente département le savent très bien
les infrastructures méritent un
entretien permanent ça va être un des
efforts importants aussi de la LPM on a
eu des débats dans l'hémicycle sur le
SCAR sur le sur le SSA sur les
infrastructures d'autres sont revenus
sur le MCO qui donc en creux aussi pose
la question de la disponibilité des
matériels et aussi du niveau d'activité
que l'on attend bon ça ce sont des
lignes qui vont être en forte
augmentation évidemment dans la copie
que je vous présenterai au mois de mars
avril je pense que les forces sur les
infrastructures il est clés je pense
qu'on a aussi mais jamais dans un
instant des efforts à faire de
simplification au sein du ministère
conduite de ces projets je suis quand
même frappé de voir que il est parfois
plus facile de construire un quai de
SNLE que de construire la cantine des
sous-mariniers dans lequel les
sous-mariniers iront mangé bon c'est
ainsi donc je n'en tire aucune aucun
reproche pour les équipes qui font un
travail remarquable mais c'est le rôle
du politique et du ministre
singulièrement que d'apporter aussi des
solutions de simplification avec
quelques décisions évidemment sur sur
cette affaire je pense aussi que je le
disais il est important de de
questionner aussi
je serais heureux aussi d'entendre les
contributions de chaque formation
politique sur cette affaire c'est aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on souhaite faire seul
qu'est-ce que l'on souhaite faire à
plusieurs
alors je sais que les questions liées à
l'OTAN ou à l'Union européenne ne sont
pas toujours consensuelles mais enfin la
France n'est pas une île et d'ailleurs
si on la veut puissante par définition
on ne peut pas la souhaiter isoler donc
là aussi je pense que c'est un sujet clé
qu'est-ce que l'on apporte à nos alliés
qu'est-ce que l'on attend de nos alliés
pour le capacitaire on pense toujours
beaucoup très vite ce Scaff etc enfin on
peut aussi très vite regarder les
coopérations matières maritimes on voit
bien qu'on a un agenda de sécurité en
Méditerranée important à tenir que c'est
un espace qui va devenir parfois tendu
parce que parce que lutte contre les
migration parce que fond sous-marin
câble sous-marin parce que trafic entre
genre parce qu'évidemment
présente russe qui tant parfois à
entretenir des difficultés de d'accès ou
des déni d'accès dans les eaux dans les
eaux qui sont qui sont libres
normalement de circulation bon on voit
bien que la Méditerranée est un enjeu de
sécurité pour nous autres bon bah là
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
Italiens qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
Grecs qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
chipriotes qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
Espagnols dans une autre mesure
qu'est-ce que l'on fait hors Union
européenne avec les Algériens sont
autant de sujets qui doivent aussi nous
faire réfléchir à notre modèle de marine
je donne cet exemple là mais je pourrais
évidemment le déployer sur d'autres
sujets en tout cas il faudra évidemment
regarder cette affaire avec beaucoup de
précision et que chacun dise aussi quels
sont les alliances qu'il souhaite
soutenir puisque ça donnera aussi le
format d'armée alors le travail continue
évidemment un projet de loi qui est pas
encore complètement stabilisé déjà parce
que je souhaite un large tour de piste
avec la BITD avec nos entreprises j'ai
commencé à après arbitrer sous
l'autorité du Président de la République
des cibles capacitaires
un niveau qu'on pourrait dire brouillon
V0 en quelque sorte pour permettre à la
DGA de rentrer en discussion avec nos
industriels nos industriels font partie
notre modèle de souveraineté on dit les
années 60 la dissuasion le modèle
d'armée il y a aussi des entreprises
pour ne pas être condamné à acheter à
Moscou Pékin ou Washington il faut donc
pouvoir acheter à Paris pour acheter à
Paris il faut donc avoir une BTD avec
évidemment un savoir-faire important
enfin aussi des coûts qui sont
soutenables pour nos finances publiques
et pour notre armée puis aussi des
délais qui devient un sujet évidemment
particulièrement parce que l'aide à
l'Ukraine a évidemment réveillé aussi ce
sujet dont on se dit bah oui en cas
d'attrition très forte de nos matériels
ou de nos munitions comment on fait pour
très très vite recompléter les stocks
c'est les questions que vous m'avez à
juste titre largement posé sur lesquels
on César je note que Nexter a fait des
efforts importants ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que là je souhaite que la
DGA puisse faire un large tour d'horizon
pour traiter un certain nombre de sujets
le premier c'est effectivement comment
les industriels regardent la gestion de
leur stock dans les années qui viennent
les industriels nous ont dit pour
définir les stocks il faut qu'on ait de
la visibilité bon 413 milliards d'euros
avec un rapport annexé et une liste de
d'équipements que le Parlement votera
que vous amenderez peut-être aussi sans
doute enfin en tout cas que la
représentation nationale va voter je
connais peu de l'entreprise qui
disposent de 50 visibilité avec un texte
légal et une enveloppe bon maintenant il
faut la visibilité elle est donnée il y
a toujours ceux qui diront c'est pas
assez c'est pas suffisant etc bon en
tout cas d'arrêter c'est que cette
visibilité elle est elle est donnée puis
elle est pas à la baisse
donc ça doit quand même déjà susciter
une forme d'enthousiasme bon deuxième
des choses au delà des stocks capacité à
sincériser les délais de livraison ces
clés parce que on a aussi une courbe à
tracer il y a l'augmentation mais aussi
le rythme de cette augmentation année
par année au moment où je vous parle
évidemment pas de chiffres à donner
parce que c'est aussi la capacité à
produire et à livrer la commande c'est
l'autorisation d'engagement le crédit de
paiement et le versement de ce crédit de
paiement c'est la livraison du matériel
dans nos armées donc ça c'est c'est un
des casse-têtes de la de la
programmation c'est aussi de s'assurer
qu'on a bien un rythme de production qui
correspond aussi au rythme de livraison
attendue et ça ça nous permettra
évidemment d'affiner la copie la copie
budgétaire ce qui est vrai également
aussi pour la négociation des prix
unitaires lorsqu'on a acheté moins de
matériel c'était pas forcément une
situation où l'État était en position de
force pour négocier quelques prix dès
lors que vous prenez certains segments
capacitaires et qu'on va peut-être en
acheter plus que ce qu'on aurait imaginé
ou ce qui était prévu pas évidemment moi
je vais demander à la DGA de rentrer
dans une phase de négociation pour
réduire un certain nombre de prix
unitaires de ces équipements et puis
enfin dernier point stratégie
exportation je rappelle que depuis les
années 60 notre modèle de BITD même si
je sais que ce sujet n'est pas toujours
consensuel là aussi mais ce modèle de
BTD repose aussi sur une part de succès
à l'export bon et donc de capacité aussi
pour la France et les Français de faire
rayonner aussi le savoir-faire et pas
que de créer de l'emploi et la richesse
et Dieu sait que c'est important de
créer l'emploi mais aussi pour être en
situation d'être aussi en soutien en
quelque sorte de notre diplomatie et je
note que dans la dopacifique je me suis
rendu en Inde Indonésie aux Émirats
arabes unis aussi notre diplomatie
d'allier mes non alignés créent aussi un
intérêt profond pour la plupart de nos
de nos partenaires y compris sur des
segments capacitaires qui vont venir
aussi nous aider à venir stabiliser un
modèle économique en tout cas le mois de
février est assurément le Mois de
l'économie de guerre
je crois comprendre par les questions
que les journalistes me posaient que nos
amis industriels attendaient un peu de
concret ces choses faites ils vont
l'avoir en la personne des manuels qui
va et de Thierry Carlier et donc c'est
évidemment c'est une bonne chose l'autre
champ de travail évidemment c'est le
budgétaire et normatif on va continuer
de travailler mais je répondrai à vos
questions et puis enfin évidemment il y
a il y a une copie ressources humaines
RH qui est importante il faut pas
souvent dans les LPM le capacitaire peut
très vite tout absorber or on le sait
notre modèle d'armée s'il fonctionne
c'est aussi parce que évidemment il y a
des spécificités de ressources humaines
dans le modèle d'armée c'est vrai de nos
écoles c'est vrai du système aussi en
flux évidemment de nos armées et donc
c'est tout ce qui a été évoqué autour du
plan famille évidemment autour de la
gestion des dossiers de nos de nos
blessés sur lequel évidemment il faut
avancer on voit bien qu'il faut aller
au-delà ça pose aussi désormais des
questions sur certains métiers de
fidélisation ce qu'on voit bien que sur
certaines fonctions
notre jeunesse est contente de venir
rentrer au ministère des armées mais
malheureusement ne reste pas
suffisamment longtemps pour donner à
notre institution toutes leurs forces
sur sur la durée donc ça c'est
évidemment un des dossiers qu'il faudra
travailler la réserve qui va quand même
être une un changement je vois bien la
manière le sujet réserve est traité
donne l'impression que c'est c'est juste
pour augmenter le nombre de réservistes
non quand vous serons dans une armée
dans lequel vous aurez un ratio de deux
points
de actifs pour un réserviste vous serez
dans une modification profonde de
l'organisation des choses quand on
imaginera les missions européen
opérationnelles ou le cas échanges les
Opex avec aussi un ratio de réserviste
en son sein c'est une modification douce
lente agréable plus agréable pour
l'armée de terre que ce qu'elle a pu
quand même dans les années 60 c'est une
évidence mais ça va être une
modification quand même du modèle
d'organisation des armées donc à la fois
on convoque les forces morales enfin on
va aussi réinterroger tout doucement ce
modèle l'organisation dans lequel on va
s'appuyer aussi sur les réservistes
opérationnel officier comme
sous-officier mais aussi homme Durand et
ça évidemment c'est un point aussi très
très important sur lequel j'aurai
l'occasion et tout dernier point et je
me tais je lancerai en parallèle un
chantier de simplification important au
sein du ministère j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire pour l'économie de guerre et
pour la DGA je constate que ce ministère
n'a au fond il est ni décentralisé ni
déconcentré mais il est pas plus
Jacobins pour autant
c'est à dire que on a beaucoup de
fonctions qui doivent être jacobine ces
ministère des armées on ne comprendra
bien que tout doit remonter au chef
d'état-major des armées au ministre
enfin un peu plus c'est l'armée et en
même temps on voit bien que sur beaucoup
de petites fonctions du quotidien dans
la vie d'un régiment dans la vie d'une
base aérienne ou d'une base navale ou
d'un bateau beaucoup de décisions sont
confisquées au chef de corps pour les
faire remonter dans une forme de
bureaucratie qui me semble à mon avis
superflu désormais donc ça c'est un
mouvement que je vais appeler de mes
vœux que je vais mener en parallèle de
la LPM chez le président et de et
d'essayer de faire un choc de confiance
et de déconcentration d'un certain
nombre de décisions et donc en repartant
des chefs de corps parce que je respec
persuadais que nos colonel et capitaine
de vaisseau sont
une strat en tout cas qui est la plus
intéressante à bien des égards dans
l'organisation de nos armées pour pour
travailler à ça et je crois que ça fait
longtemps que tout le monde en parle je
sais que le sujet n'est pas que facile à
traiter en tout cas je vais m'y employé
puisque les sommes que l'on que l'on va
attribuer à nos armées dans les temps
qui viendront sont pas de sens si en
parallèle on ne touche pas aussi aux
mesures qui peuvent permettre de
débloquer de l'énergie et de recréer
aussi de la confiance en masse dans
l'organisation et la structure du
ministère c'est l'éternel dilemme armé
en temps de guerre armée entendent P on
forme le vœu qu'on soit en temps de P
l'enfant doit être capable de passer
d'un état à l'autre avec beaucoup plus
de facilité et d'organisation voilà
monsieur le Président ce que je pouvais
dire à titre introductif de cette
nouvelle séquence autour de toi de
programmation militaire merci monsieur
le ministre nous allons prendre les
interventions des 10 orateurs de groupe
et je vois déjà 18 demandes
d'intervention complémentaires donc
personne ne voudra aux orateurs de
groupe de ne pas totalement utiliser
leur temps de parole de 3 minutes pour
le groupe Renaissance la parole est à
Yannick chenevard
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
d'abord citer Clémenceau qui disait il
faut d'abord savoir ce que l'on veut
quand on le sait il faut avoir le
courage de le dire quand on le dit il
faut avoir l'énergie de le faire va nous
y sommes
295 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
de l'actuel loi de programmation
militaire une LPM vous l'avez dit
Monsieur ministre de réparation de nos
armées qui furent condamnés à toucher
les vides de la paix durant 30 ans et
qui se relève depuis 2018-2019
n'oublions pas de rappeler combien son
exécution à l'euro le relève de
l'exploit de la volonté politique au
regard des années antérieures cette LPM
est déjà à saluée comme un exploit notre
BITD a su s'adapter et doit encore le
faire
413 milliards de milliards d'euros entre
2024 et 2030 qui pouvait imaginer un tel
nouveau saut que dis-je un bon
supplémentaire pour avoir une guerre
d'avance
mais le monde a changé et les empires
sont de retour monsieur le ministre nous
n'avions pas attendu la guerre en
Ukraine pour transformer nos armées les
réparer cependant dans la future LPM je
note plus 60% de crédit pour le
renseignement le doublement de ceux de
la DRM et de la drsd ou la place
centrale de nos outre-mer par exemple
sont-ils également des enseignements de
ce conflit
en doublant quasiment les crédits de la
LPM ce qui va se traduire par de force
de commandes sur notre pour notre BITD
quel place imaginez-vous pour la
coopération européenne sur quel projet
en particulier
enfin nos armées ne valent que par
celles et ceux qui les servent 500
millions d'euros ont été consacrés à la
nprm dans l'actuel LPM ils étaient
bienvenus l'avenir passe aussi sans
doute par la modification de la grille
indiciaire de nos militaires je n'ai
absolument aucun doute sur le fait que
ce sera le cas monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le budget de nos armées
c'est la part que la nation consacre à
la défense de notre démocratie afin que
tout le reste tout le reste vive
pas de démocratie pas de liberté sans
armée puissante je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le député
chenvar bon merci de revenir sur
l'exploit parce que souvent gâteau avalé
n'a plus de goût donc tout le monde
trouve ça normal et même des gens qui
disent oui ça devrait être encore plus à
moins à moins de 430 milliards ça vaut
pas le coup pourquoi 430 on sait pas
très bien
pourquoi pas 429 431 bon donc c'est
toujours un peu un peu curieux quand
même d'un mot bon 413 milliards je
reviendrai sur 413 400 parce que je sais
qu'il y a des questions sur le sujet
on est
comme elle a dit le président de la
République il y a rien de superflu dans
la copie on est déjà sur une copie qui a
été compressée challenger ramassé
les lois de programmation sont ce
qu'elles sont elles ne peuvent pas
traiter tous les imprévus donc de toute
façon les parlementaires restent
souverains dans chaque loi de finance
pour ouvrir les autorisations
d'engagement des crédits de paiement je
le redis parce que la programmation elle
fige une stratégie mais c'est quand même
les lois de finance annuelles qui
viennent quand même permettre au
gouvernement de faire un certain nombre
de choses il faut le dire de manière
clairement deux sous questions
coopération européenne nprm coopération
européenne il est très clair que on a
toujours un enjeu industriel soit autour
d'entreprise que nous avons déjà en
partage parfois on dit pas assez souvent
MBDA avec l'Italie et la Grande-Bretagne
vendrait d'ailleurs à Rome ce vendredi
pour parler justement de l'avenir de
mvda évidemment des coopérations en
matière spatiale qui sont parfois
civiles mais enfin qui peuvent avoir une
implication en incrément mil évidemment
des entreprises comme Airbus aussi pour
citer qu'elle et des programmes que l'on
connaît
occasion de revenir évidemment sur le
Scaff sur le mgcs etc qui sont des
coopérations qui sont qui sont utiles
parce qu'elles permettent aussi de
rendre absorbables budgétairement un
certain nombre d'efforts comme le redire
notamment sur le Scaff pour regarder
deuxième des choses je pense que
l'esprit de takuba est quand même un bel
esprit et que pour la première fois la
France a emmené en européen aussi des
capacités d'intervention en Afrique je
pense que la question de nadop Pacifique
est un des éléments de réflexion que
l'on peut faire en européen en tout cas
moi je préfère qu'on le fasse en
européen qu'au sein de l'OTAN pour dire
les choses très directement parce que
dans cette antique est Atlantique elle
est pas Pacifique donc je pense qu'on a
l'Afrique comme l'Indo-Pacifique sont
des sujets et moi je forme aussi le vœu
que les parlementaires dans les inter
parlementaires avec les autres
puissances européennes puisse traiter de
ces sujets parce que c'est absolument
clé troisième sujet l'aide à l'Ukraine
qui reste d'actualité on voit que la
facilité européenne de paix qu'on nous
avions imaginé sous présence française
qui était plutôt consacrée à l'Afrique
initialement aujourd'hui évidemment
permet d'aider massives en l'Ukraine on
a aussi un outil qui nous permet de
traiter ça en européen donc autant de
sujets soit par des instruments
budgétaires soit par des instruments ou
des coopérations industriels ou des
entreprises soit par de l'opérationnel
c'est-à-dire takuba ça repose la
question
UTM pour la formation initiative
européenne d'intervention il y a des
objets concrets et donc il faut pas les
balayer d'un verre de main évidemment
ils sont dans la copie nprm d'un seul
mot d'un seul on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir il y a l'indiciaire pour
l'indice il y a un indemnitaire les 500
millions d'euros étaient évidemment les
bienvenus et on continuera évidemment de
travailler sur le chantier indemnitaire
je précise bien des militaires dans la
copie LPM voilà en quelques mots merci
monsieur le ministre pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est
alors jacobelli merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez évoqué lors des vœux aux armées
le président de la République a livré
quelques pistes sur la future loi de
programmation militaire il y a d'abord
un objectif transformer nos armées et
des moyens pour le faire 400 milliards
ou 413
on prend en compte la revente du parti
du
patrimoine de l'armée 413 milliards
c'est une belle somme il faut le
reconnaître une somme qui apporte de
notre part un certain nombre de
questions monsieur le ministre tout
d'abord nul ne serait
ignoré l'inflation record que nous
subissons l'explosion du cou des
matières premières et ma première
question sera celle-là comment avez-vous
intégré dans ces 400 ou 413 milliards le
suivi de cette inflation et comment
réagir si jamais les choses ne
s'amélioreraient pas de plus ce budget
est conséquent il faut maintenant
l'employer et d'ailleurs la question est
est-il employable parce que en effet on
a évoqué notre industrie de défense
notre BITD qui a beaucoup souffert des
des baisses d'investissement il y a
quelques années de perte de contrat à
l'étranger mais il va falloir derrière
quel produit et quel produit ils en
quantité êtes-vous sûr que tous les
moyens sont mis à disposition et vous
nous rassurer peut-être monsieur le
ministre pour être capable de délivrer
il faut anticiper donner des objectifs à
long terme mais aussi et surtout
préserver nos fleurons nationaux parlez
de souveraineté j'en parle aussi
volontiers et excusez-moi de le dire
mais ce gouvernement qui est prêt à
mettre 400 milliards sur la table et
nous en félicitons est aussi celui qui a
laissé passer une entreprise par exemple
comme excellia dans les mains des
Américains et Célia qui je le rappelle
est fournisseurs de nombreux composants
pour nos industriels de défense
relocaliser notre industrie c'est bien
la relocaliser en France monsieur le
ministre vous l'avouerez c'est mieux 400
milliards c'est précieux et vous allez
probablement continuer à vouloir
développer des programmes avec d'autres
pays pourquoi pas si c'est utile mais si
c'est te de idéologie qu'il ne le faut
pas parce que c'est sinon n'aboutiront
pas aboutiront tard ou aboutiront mal et
j'aimerais à nouveau évoquer le Scaff ou
le mgcs ici enfin et mon collection Var
a dit c'est 400 milliards doivent aussi
servir aux hommes et aux femmes qui
servent notre nation l'actuel et le PM
que nous regardons avec beaucoup
d'intérêts et curiosités à montrer
certaines réussites et certaines
faiblesses la faiblesse par exemple pour
fidéliser les talents pour entraîner
pour former pour héberger dignement ceux
qui donnent leur vie à la défense de la
nation le matériel le plus performant
technologiquement n'est rien s'il n'y a
personne en face pour le faire
fonctionner là aussi si vous pouviez
nous donner quelques éléments ne vous en
serions reconnaissant et enfin pour
terminer Monsieur le Ministre 400
milliards c'est une chance mais c'est
aussi un défi ce défi vous ne réussirez
pas seul et ce défi de la souveraineté
de l'attractivité du souffle patriotique
vous devrez impliquer le Parlement
probablement plus que ça n'a été fait et
je vous demande enfin si ce copilotage
avec le Parlement notamment en cas de
changement d'investissement ou de
voilure vous êtes prêts à le faire avec
nous merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
chers collègues peut-être pour les
prochaines questions si vous pouvez
peut-être concentrer un peu les
questions puisque le ministre ne dispose
que de quelques minutes pour répondre et
même si à l'esprit de santé très aiguisé
impossible d'une des peu tenue oui c'est
moi jeter une histoire
plusieurs choses un bon déjà c'est 413
milliards de dépenses militaires 400
milliards de d'expressions de besoins de
recettes budgétaires pour être précis
donc la copie en dépense militaire et
413 milliards de les recettes extra
budgétaires contrairement à peut-être
contre toute attente et moi-même j'en
fuis le premier surpris pour être
honnête avec vous ce ne sont pas les
sessions de patrimoine figurez-vous mais
c'est le service de santé des armées par
les tarifications à l'acte dans les
hôpitaux et c'est pas du tout
négligeable puisque ces 3 milliards
d'euros sur la période donc le service
Santé des Armées par définition un
système de recettes pareil pour la DRM
qui ou d'autres services qui tarifient
avec certains partenaires de l'imagerie
ou des prestations intellectuelles donc
il se trouve que on a repris les taux de
ressources extra budgétaires des
périodes précédentes de manière prudente
en se disant que c'était voilà je pense
que j'aimerais dans un instant
l'inflation au moment où nous parlons
nous sommes bien élevés donc nous avons
évidemment pris les critères de Bercy ce
qui est toujours dans une conversation
et donc nous avons évidemment établi
cette inflation en impact au moment où
nous parlons sur les 413 milliards un
impact autour de 30 milliards alors
après l'inflation on en parle quand elle
est mauvaise quand elle est bonne c'est
à dire négative personne n'en parle donc
moi je vous propose aussi de faire le
vœu devant vous suivant un si
l'inflation devait être favorable pour
les acheteurs publics dans les années
qui viennent je propose de ne pas faire
de bourrage avec des objets qui ne sont
pas prévus dans la LPM initialement ce
qu'on voit bien quand on a un
retournement de tendance il faut
absorber l'effort ça je pense qu'il faut
l'assumer et inversement si c'est
défavorable il faut se dire en
conscience que l'outil report de charge
sert à cela que c'est pas un tabou donc
en tout cas je vois bien qu'on pourrait
faire de la politique avec cette affaire
mais enfin mon avis c'est intéressant le
report de charge est évidemment pas un
tabou et ensuite vous l'avez dit
retourner devant le Parlement pour
demander des crédits nouveaux pour
compenser pour pas besoin militaires
immédiat doit être fait et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas assez dit mais c'est ce que
j'ai fait devant vous en collectif
budgétaire et on peut les faire cette
année on a pratiquement réouvert aide à
l'Ukraine inflation point d'indice un
milliard d'euros en collectif budgétaire
donc ça c'est pour vous répondre de
manière précise sur les questions liées
à l'inflation et sur le fait que moi je
suis favorable associé le plus possible
Parlement voilà parce que je pense que
c'est la condition de l'acceptabilité
sociétale et sociale des choix qui sont
faits si généralement la choisit les
lois de programmation c'est aussi pour
ça d'ailleurs d'autres propositions lui
avaient été faites y compris pour ne pas
assumer très clairement la dissuasion
devant le Parlement il a souhaité que le
Parlement se prononce sur la dissuasion
d'ailleurs pas été déçu du voyage
puisque à l'époque je vous rappelle que
la première loi de programmation
militaire a été adoptée par 49-3 par
trois fois que le scénar fusée de la
discuter bref pour des raisons très
différentes donc en tout cas général le
Gaule lui-même a voulu aussi le moment
de vérité moi je pense que vu les
circonstances dans lequel le pays se
trouve avec les menaces telles que nous
connaissons plus on parle des problèmes
de sécurité qui pèsent sur la nation
française à l'ASSE international au
Sénat plus c'est une bonne chose et ça
permet évidemment de confronter les
différentes les différentes opinions
Scaff en trois minutes je n'avais pas le
temps mais je le ferai sur une autre
question la stratégie pour délivrer BITD
export je le ferai aussi sur une autre
question
le ministre pour le groupe 1 France
insoumise la parole est à bassin à chaud
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous remercie pour votre
exposé éliminaire votre cours d'histoire
et votre explication du discours du
président
l'Assemblée nationale a été une nouvelle
fois méprisée l'exécutif réservant sa
parole à la presse et non aux
représentants du peuple français vous
nous indiquiez votre volonté de
co-construire la loi de programmation
militaire avec le Parlement finalement
le président s'est exprimé seul sur un
montant sans que celui-ci n'ait été
débattu nulle part mis à part dans vos
réunions interministérielles comme pour
la revue nationale stratégique le
président fait des annonces en grande
pompe sans véritable débat au préalable
les groupes de travail apparaissent
cruments comme ceux qui le sont un
affichage de co-construction déjà que
leur rôle était fort circonscrit aucune
discussion n'était possible ni sur la
doctrine ni sur le budget le roi est
maintenant nu un exemple le doublement
de la réserve nous n'avons pas puni
discuter ni des raisons ni des objectifs
de ce doublement seulement du comment
vous avez voulu transformer les
parlementaires en nageant de la
communication gouvernementale vous êtes
maintenant démasqué les députés de la
France insoumise ont décidé de suspendre
leur participation à ces groupes de
travail et nous eu au jourons donc de
notre droit constitutionnel à un
amendement sur ce texte nous proposons
également un projet alternatif dans la
lignée du programme défense porté par
notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon et si
cela vous dérange vous aurez toujours
l'opportunité d'utiliser le 49-3 comme
Madame borne en a l'habitude pour faire
adopter cette LPM et définitivement
bâillonner le Parlement sur un sujet
essentiel pour notre pays et nos
concitoyens sur lequel vous auriez pu
chercher un véritable consensus nous
constatons que ce n'est pas votre
volonté nous serons particulièrement
attentifs à la condition de vie de nos
militaires à la revalorisation de la
part indiciaire de leur rémunération et
à la prise en charge des blessés nous
porterons des propositions sur le
spatial le cyber ou encore les fonds
marins nous veillerons à ce que vos
décisions de cession d'armement de
maîtrise pas les capacités de nos armées
comme vous l'avez fait pour l'armée de
l'air en vendant des rafales à la Grèce
et à la Croatie nous serons vigilants à
ce que nos trois armées soient
satisfaites dans leurs besoins
opérationnels quels et les moyens de
s'entraîner et d'assurer la sécurité de
nos concitoyens face aux menaces du
monde actuel y compris celle liée au
changement climatique
évidemment nous serons intransigeants
sur les coopérations européennes en
matière d'armement notamment sur le SCAF
ou sur le mgcs ou la nécessité de plan B
nationaux semble de plus en plus
nécessaire l'abandon de la modernisation
du tigre est un exemple frappant et
avant le débat sur la LPM vous nous
trouverez sur votre chemin pour
s'opposer à votre soi-disant réforme des
retraites qui va frapper les militaires
au même titre que l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens et face à laquelle le peuple
se dressera une nouvelle fois le 31
janvier je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
[Musique]
la dernière fois en audition c'était
parce que j'étais venu avec trop
d'officiers généraux autour de moi et
donc vous m'avez interpellé sur ce sujet
de forme de l'audition et quand je vous
ai répondu d'ailleurs mais je ne suis
pas rancunier vous étiez déjà parti la
première audition c'était encore un
autre sujet de forme mais une fois plus
je ne vous en veux pas donc je vis ça
avec beaucoup de sympathie plus que la
forme moi je forme le vœu qu'on parle du
fond je pense que les Français ont
besoin aussi de savoir et comprendre ce
que la nups France insoumise propose sur
notre diffusion nucléaire j'ai pas
toujours tout compris sur évidemment
notre appartenance à l'OTAN ça me semble
très compliqué évidemment de de
comprendre notre modèle l'armée si on le
dit ceci nos alliances militaires pour
le dans le train qui m'emmené de la
Pologne vers l'Ukraine Jules le bonheur
de lire votre livre sur la Russie
monsieur député Lachaud il y a
maintenant de cela quelques mois que
vous avez écrit c'est intéressant et je
pense que puisque vous vous interrogez
sur les coopérations européennes j'aurai
l'occasion moi aussi d'interroger les
différentes formations politiques sur la
relation que vous avec Pékin avec Moscou
mais aussi évidemment avec Londres
Washington ou Berlin mais je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un sujet qui
mérite de faire carte sur table et qu'il
y a de la place ici pour parler du fond
en tout cas je suis heureux de vous
retrouver
merci monsieur le ministre
pour le pour le groupe les républicains
la parole est à Jean-Louis Thiery
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre quel bonheur de voir que le
temps des dividendes de la paix et des
conséquences catastrophiques qu'elles
ont amenées sur nos armées est enfin
tournée 413 milliards c'est
effectivement une somme importante et il
serait extrêmement malvenu après ce qui
a été le passé de s'en plaindre même si
comme chacun sait le diable et dans les
détails et donc ce sera ce seront les
détails qui nous permettront d'avoir un
avis complet vous avez parlé d'un modèle
complet mais pas comme avant et donc la
question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on ne fera
plus comme avant évidemment ce sera le
moment de de l'évaluer pour le moment je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur des
sujets budgétaires 413 milliards dans
ces 413 milliards 400 milliards de
ressources budgétaires 13 milliards de
ressources extra budgétaire vous avez
partiellement répondu à la question sur
les ressources extra budgétaires ma
question est si ces ressources sont
inférieures à ce qui est prévu même s'il
apparemment vous avez pris les ratios
précédents qu'est-ce qui est prévu
est-ce que vous pensez que cela doit
donner lieu à une compensation d'ordre
budgétaire deuxième question je reviens
sur l'inflation on sait que sur cette
question de l'inflation on a l'inflation
générale que l'on connaît qui touche la
totalité de l'économie on a une
inflation spécifique à l'équipement
militaire en raison de l'attention sur
des matières premières sur les
composants sur des métaux rares ou sur
les coûts de l'énergie vous évaluez
cette somme à 30 milliards dans la LPM
est-ce que indépendamment du vote des
annuités budgétaires vous avez vous
envisagez d'avoir un système
d'indexation une clause de revoyure
éventuellement une réflexion qui aurait
eu tout son sens en neuroconstant et pas
en euros courant enfin autant de
questions qui se posent donc j'aurais
souhaité savoir les réponses que vous
apportez à ce sujet je ne serai pas plus
long je veux quand même vous dire que
j'ai eu grand plaisir à vous entendre
évoquer la verticalité nécessaire de
l'ordre hiérarchique mais aussi les
subsidiarité au niveau des chefs de
corps nos chefs de corps ont beaucoup
souffert nos régiments et nos bateaux
aussi et si on peut avancer dans ce sens
là c'est évidemment très positif
monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs sur ce
dernier point merci au début des
matériaux évidemment moi je suis preneur
des des recommandations que le Parlement
peut faire sur ce sujet parce que vous
vous déployez suffisamment sur le
terrain les uns et les autres dans les
unités pour capter ici ou là des
diagnostics ou des ou des solutions
auxquelles évidemment je serai
évidemment très très sensible et très
heureux de participer bon les questions
de budgétaires évidemment elles sont
clés parce que alors dès lors qu'on
exécute à l'euro près la LPM il est
clair que plus on emmène l'exigence et
vous avez bien raison de mettre la sur
le gouvernement sur cette affaire parce
que plus ça tire tout cela vers le haut
plus ça prive aussi certains de dire
qu'il manquerait de la visibilité donc
au fond tout ça est quand même très
précieux bon je vois plusieurs éléments
de sous-réponse à votre question déjà
j'ai commencé à le dire les ressources
extra budgétaires elles ont toujours
existé elles sont parfois pas forcément
là où on croit alors c'est un peu plus
précis mais globalement on a trois
milliards d'euros sur le service de
santé des armées on a pris tout
simplement les dynamiques de la période
précédente des périodes précédentes que
l'on a reposé ici peut-être aussi à nous
d'être bon pour les optimiser et de
faire encore mieux vous avez beaucoup de
prestations de service j'ai parlé de la
DRM la DGA aussi quand même qui fait
parfois certain nombre de services
d'essai pour tiers pour compte de tiers
et sur lequel évidemment c'est devenu le
facturation c'est pas le contribuable
qu'il paie et c'est bienheureux les
sessions de matériel et les formations
qui sont associées donc là on parle pas
forcément de cession de Rafale mais tout
simplement aussi parfois dans nos
programmes d'accompagnement et de
formation sur certaines armées alliées
on a du vieux matériel qu'on va céder à
des tarifs qui sont en général qui
tiennent compte de l'usure du matériel
mais enfin ça fait quand même une
recette en tant que tel et puis jadis on
le sait très bien il y avait le casse
immobilier là on est pratiquement sur
500 millions d'euros d'estimation parce
que malheureusement tout le monde a tout
vendu avant donc il y a plus grand chose
avant donc les choses sont ainsi ainsi
faites il y a ensuite d'autres dans les
5 milliards potentiels de ressources
extra budgétaire il y a d'autres
variables de négociation de remise en
question aussi d'un certain nombre de
contrats passés je rentre pas dans les
détails mais des systèmes de dividendes
sur des situations déjà connues ou
obtenu y compris d'ailleurs sur la
dissuasion nucléaire sur lequel je serai
pas plus bavard mais sur lequel on peut
peut-être voir avec un certain nombre
d'opérateurs à reconditionner un certain
nombre de contrats avec des rentes
annuels que l'on peut casercher en faire
diminuer enfin voilà ce sont des sujets
évidemment qui sont traités sur
l'inflation alors vous avez raison il y
a une inflation générale une inflation
qu'on pourrait dire spécialement
militaire vous avez cité évidemment les
équipements bon c'est aussi la
conversation que je vais avoir avec la
BITD dans beaucoup de cas aussi et vous
avez une partie de l'inflation qui est
pris par l'entreprise donc je moi je
pense aussi que ça vaut le coup d'avoir
ça permet de répondre aux yeux députés
oui en même temps c'est dès lors qu'on
donne de la visibilité que l'on va aussi
beaucoup accompagner à l'export
en fonction des matériaux en fonction
des programmes moi je pense aussi qu'il
faut s'insériser la copie inflation avec
le l'entreprise dont l'état est client
personne ne comprendrait au nom du
contribuable qu'on ne fasse pas cet
effort-là ça c'est évidemment clé
j'aimerais également rajouter aussi le
carburant opérationnel parce que il est
l'autre grande variable dans la LPM sur
lequel il est parfois compliqué de faire
des projections les évolution du baril
de Brent mais aussi l'évolution de
l'activité des forces il y a l'activité
standard qui vont entraînement après
évidemment il y a aussi l'activité en
OPEX au cas échéant en mission
opérationnelle donc la question des
carburants fait encore l'objet
évidemment de discussion en
interministériale voilà ce que je peux
dire en trois minutes 12
merci monsieur le ministre pour le
groupe démocrate la parole est à
Jean-Pierre cubertaffond merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues notre groupe politique vous
remercie d'être présent en ce début
d'année 2023 cette année et d'importance
à l'heure nous allons bientôt nous doter
d'une nouvelle loi de programmation
militaire dont l'ambition sera
d'entretenir nos efforts militaires et
de permettre à nos armées de répondre
aux différents enjeux militaires et
politiques les grandes lignes de cette
future loi de programmation se dessine à
l'occasion de ces vœux aux armées le
président de la République a présenté
ses grandes orientations et a dit voilà
un effort budgétaire comme on l'a
signalé déjà de 413 milliards d'euros
monsieur le ministre vous rappeler
vendredi dernier que cette enveloppe
constitue une somme historique au regard
du conflit Russo
ukrainien les armées françaises
présentent néanmoins quelques lacunes
capacitaire je pense aux munitions au
système de défense solaire ou des
missiles de croisière enfin persiste des
dépenses intangibles comme l'a dit à
dissuasion nucléaire ou encore des
menaces cyberes monsieur le ministre
comment intégrez-vous les différences
enseignements du conflit ukrainien dans
les objectifs fixés par cette nouvelle
loi de programmation militaire le
président de la République indique
vouloir faire de la France une puissance
de premier rang mondiale dans le domaine
cyberg comment entendez-vous permettre à
la France de renforcer ses capacités en
la matière et de concurrencer des
puissances mondiales qui dominent ce
domaine enfin Monsieur le Ministre et ma
dernière question le président avancé à
Toulon en novembre dernier que nos
forces nucléaires contribuent par leur
existant propre à la sécurité de la
France et de l'Europe à la vue des
enjeux qui représenteraient l'adhésion
de la Suède à l'OTAN comment évoluer les
rapports de force entre puissance
européenne et comment envisagez-vous
notre organisation stratégique de
rapport à l'OTAN je vous remercie ce
sont des questions très complètes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre je vous
souhaite bon courage
non elle est question complète qui vont
donc appeler des réponses complètes je
vais le tenter le cyber mériterait que
j'y consacre au moins 3 minutes donc je
vais essayer d'être discipliné mais je
pense que ça vaut le coup de traiter ce
sujet dans le détail déjà l'accepte la
définition du mot cyber mérite d'être
faite dans la LPM parce que sinon on va
traiter toute cette sujet qui n'ont pas
forcément le lien avec le ministère des
armées en tant que première remarque
deuxième remarque on le voit bien au
fond on a trois métiers dans le cyber
protégés comme on se défend et là c'est
pas qu'un sujet minarme c'est c'est un
sujet aussi de résidence plus globale
dans votre maison vous avez j'imagine un
système d'alarme vous avez des verrous
des portes des fenêtres c'est quoi les
portes et les fenêtres de protection des
attaques cyber de demain donc qu'est-ce
qui relève de la puissance publique la
gendarmerie ou la police qu'est-ce qui
relève des protections individuelles que
vous devez avoir sur vos propres
infrastructures et n'importe quel maire
chef d'entreprise devra se poser ces
questions ça c'est un beau débat
d'ailleurs pour la commission de la
défense de manière globale parce que ça
pose aussi la question de la rôle du
contribuable et de la puissance dans
cette affaire jusqu'où on va deuxième
sujet troisième sujet après vous avez
quand même des métiers qui dépendent de
la puissance publique et singulièrement
du ministère des armées l'attribution
c'est pas le tout de savoir qu'un
hôpital est attaqué est-ce qu'on est
capable d'attribuer l'attaque acteur
étatique acteur non étatique
cybercriminalité cyber théorie
atteinte à la souveraineté par un pays
étranger la capacité tout simplement à
dire quelle est l'attaquant est
évidemment quelque chose d'absolument
clé ça vaut pour le temps de P ça vaut
pour le temps de guerre et ça c'est
évidemment un des points d'effort que je
vous proposerai dans LPM et troisième
volet évidemment entraver une fois qu'on
a attribué comment on est capable de
faire cesser une attaque en cours c'est
plus compliqué que la que la que
l'entrave afin que la protection
pardonnait moi comment on est capable de
retourner cette attaque et d'y mettre
fin voilà si je devais résumer la
doctrine sur lequel on vous proposera
des choses en LPM c'est ça derrière ça
donne lieu des chantiers
il y a évidemment un chantier
technologique qui est un métier sans fin
parce que évidemment il faut sans cesse
innover sans cesse remettre à jour il y
a aussi beaucoup de porosités avec le
cybersivil peut pas complètement
déconnecter évidemment ce que font les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet les
différents aussi leaders du monde de la
téléphonie mobile donc il y a évidemment
une
porosité entre les différents milieux
puis un chantier RH quand on parle de
fidélisation de nos de nos personnels il
est évident que là où la trission est la
plus forte au ministère des armées au
moment où je vous parle c'est sur les
métiers cyber sur lequel les jeunes les
jeunes femmes et jeunes hommes qui
viennent travailler au ministère des
armées en première expérience
professionnelle sont fiers d'acquérir
sur leur ligne de CV
le ministère des armées est très très
vite derrière au bout de quatre ou cinq
ans se font débaucher dans le secteur
privé pour des sommes somme toute
alléchantes et je ne peux pas l'en
vouloir donc le chantier de la
fidélisation le chantier RH autour de la
cyber va être extraordinairement clé
après vous avez des fonctions militaires
plus spécifiques pense qu'on y reviendra
sur lequel moi je fais que l'armée de
terre soit leader de cette affaire la
guerre électronique comment on a des
régiments qui se spécialise une forme
d'infanterie cyber en quelque sorte de
demain donc là le chef est à major de
l'armée de terre sous l'autorité du séma
a reçu quelques commandes en la matière
parce que c'est évidemment l'armée de
terre pour des raisons évidentes qui
peut qui peut emmener l'ensemble de
notre modèle d'armée sur cette affaire
là dissuasion en quelques secondes ça me
semble compliqué néanmoins
plus que jamais elle est utile
plus que jamais elle protège nos
intérêts vitaux
et plus que jamais chaque génération de
décideur doit prendre les bonnes
décisions pour la génération qui suit
jusqu'au fond les instruments de la
dissuasion d'aujourd'hui sont plutôt des
décisions d'hier avec des décisions de
financement d'un avant-hier et donc les
décisions que vous apprêterez à prendre
cette programmation militaire et ce
n'est le 3G enfin l'ensemble des
différents programmes que vous
connaissez c'est pour au-delà de la
nature et de la LPM bien souvent mais
donc la dissuasion mérite toujours ce
temps de réflexion à 5 10 15 ans et je
me réjouis que le président ait choisi
de faire un cycle dédié d'audition sur
cette affaire parce que ça doit aussi
nous permettre d'avoir une culture
stratégique commune qui permet aussi de
mieux comprendre les sommes que nous que
nous déployons après le rétexte Ukraine
je pense qu'on y reviendra en commission
dédiée mais évidemment munitions
évidemment soutien évidemment logistique
évidemment renseignement évidemment
cyber bref beaucoup de sujets pour le
groupe socialiste la parole est à
anapick
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement reconnaissons que
les forts budgétaires étaient
nécessaires et nous l'avons d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises soulignées ici notre
groupe la souligner les dernières
annonces relatives à la future loi de
programmation militaire se font une
nouvelle fois l'écho d'un effort
d'adaptation permanent en ces temps de
guerre toutefois plusieurs points nous
interrogent à propos des annonces
présidentielles premièrement évoquer
l'idée d'une économie de guerre ne
suffit pas à faire oublier les défis
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
s'agissant des conditions de
possibilités de soutenabilité des
demandes faites à nos industrielles
auxquelles vous signalez leur manque
d'anticipation et de prise de risque
dans une interview accordée à Usine
Nouvelle comment gagner les futurs
guerres quand la guerre présente
perturbe la cheminement et provoque une
pénurie de matières premières et de
composants pour nos industriels et que
la main d'oeuvre dans ce secteur manque
comme vous le reconnaissiez vous-même en
juillet dernier deuxièmement si
l'augmentation budgétaire de nos armées
est à saluer qu'en est-il concrètement
dans la réalisation de ces nouvelles
missions
brandir le pivot de la haute intensité
signifie-t-il la perte de la projection
de nos armées comme savoir faire
français reconnu sommes-nous en capacité
de maintenir cette compétence tout en
transformant nos armées au regard du
retour de la confrontation territoriale
en Europe nos forces sont aussi des
forces employées et les temps de
formation s'allonge du fait de matériel
plus complexe et nombre de jours de
préparation ne peut pas augmenter de
manière très importante aussi si la LPM
mentionne le rôle des armées dans la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
pourriez-vous apporter des éléments de
précision sur cette mission et les
moyens mis en place pour la réaliser et
enfin cette guerre d'avance invite à
réfléchir sur le route le rôle que
souhaite avoir la France dans l'Union
européenne ainsi que le projet européen
de défense qui en découle s'agit-il de
ce coordonner ou bien de prendre un
éventuel leadership sur une éventuelle
défense européenne
si une collection européenne de défense
voyez le jour quelle mission regarde de
celle attribuée aujourd'hui que nous
attribuons aujourd'hui à l'OTAN ou en
tout cas quelle maîtrise nous aurions
sur ces aspects de coordination avec le
temps merci Monsieur le Ministre oui
merci beaucoup madame la députée bon BTD
j'ai déjà en partie répondu la question
des stocks elle est clés moi je vous le
redis
des entreprises qui ont des marchés
potentielles à l'export doivent prendre
des risques enfin
secret de polichinelle de dire que le
Caden César visiblement connaît une
forme de succès donc on peut pas
demander la même risque à une entreprise
sur un objet qui a du succès à l'export
que évidemment sur un matériel qui ne
connaît pas le succès les sports ou qui
n'a pas vocation être exporté évidemment
l'exemple évident du SNLE dans
l'interview que vous que vous avez cité
mais je pense que c'est sain d'avoir une
BITD athlétique je pense que c'est ce
que l'on doit aussi aux armées mais
c'est ce que l'on doit aussi
contribuables donc je le dis parce que
je suis le ministre de la BITD donc par
définition mon propos n'est que
bienveillance mais je pense que c'est
l'exigence aussi qui fait la
bienveillance et qui fera aussi qu'on
protégera cette BD pour les années qui
viennent et ce qu'on est capable de se
dire droit dans les yeux que notre
modèle de souveraineté industrielle il
est protégé pour les 50 années qui
viennent non et donc on fait ce que l'on
peut avec évidemment cette augmentation
budgétaire importante vous avez cité
vous-même des défis sur la main d'oeuvre
etc ce sont des choses qui sont pas
propres d'ailleurs à l'industrie
d'armement ça ça dépasse évidemment de
là ce secteur mais il est évident que il
ne faut pas que le système de
programmation conduise à éteindre toute
forme de prise de risque je le dis comme
je le pense c'est c'est ce que nos
Grands Anciens ont demandé à la BTD et
c'est ce que je vous propose
effectivement de continuer à faire parce
que c'est absolument clé sur ensuite
l'ensemble de vos sous questions je
pense que effectivement ce à 413
milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire avec un effort capacité
important plus notre disposition
effectivement ce modèle d'armée qui est
une armée d'emplois des capacités
expéditionnaires énormes dans les airs
en mer évidemment sur la terre qui est
une armée qui prend soin de ses blessés
des familles de situer enfin je veux
dire on vient de loin historiquement
donc tout ça participe évidemment à
l'épaisseur aussi de ce que de ce que
nous sommes en modèle d'armée de manière
identitaire il est évident que ça nous
conduit à être leader à devoir et
pouvoir être leader quand je dis dans le
monde ce week-end que c'est ce qui nous
permet de rester une puissance mondiale
je le pense sincèrement c'est à dire que
sans cet effort là je pense que
malheureusement on connaîtrait un
déclassement des classements parce qu'on
investirait pas le cyber on investirait
pas le spatial des classements parce que
bah on voit bien que le modèle d'armée
emploi de plus en plus de numérique et
de technologie sur le terrain je veux
dire si vous regardez scorpion pour voir
qu'en disant de temps tout ça est
spectaculaire donc je pense que vous
avez raison de souligner ensuite la
qu'est-ce que ça doit vouloir dire sur
la coopération et la coordination entre
Union européenne et autant ça je pense
que c'est un sujet qui est absolument
clé je l'ai dit au détour d'une phrase
tout à l'heure sur Afrique et
indopacifique c'est vrai sur sur
d'autres sujets être nationcadre c'est
une capacité à emmener les autres si on
est capable de le faire dans le cadre de
l'OTAN en Roumanie c'est qu'on est
capable de faire dans d'autres formes de
coalition et sur d'autres secteurs y
compris en retard et c'est pour ça que
j'ai cité takuba tout à l'heure à la
question qui m'était posée et ça pardon
c'est le et d'un mot pardon d'exposer le
temps monsieur le Président c'est le
vrai grand retour d'expérience non pas
de l'Ukraine mais de la première guerre
du Golfe dont on va enfin solder cette
affaire là première guerre du Golf on
n'est pas indépendant et on n'est pas
autonome en matière de renseignement on
dépend largement de nos alliés la
décision prend présent Mitterrand c'est
évidemment la DRM et on va y revenir
mais le renseignement va continuer de
faire l'objet d'un effort concret guerre
du Golf on est présent dans pratiquement
aucun état-major à haut niveau et les
missions opérationnelles qui sont
confiées à l'armée française sont des
missions ne le prenez pas mal mais qu'on
pourrait dire d'un second rang en tout
cas qui n'était pas dans le cœur de
l'action pour dire les choses très
clairement
c'est pas une situation dont on peut
satisfaire là il est clair que ce qu'on
va vous proposer au mois de mars avril
permettra justement durablement
d'emmener les autres à tous les étages
sur du soutien sur de l'État majeur sur
une capacité logistique ça veut pas dire
qu'on saura tout faire nous-même pas la
prétention d'être un niveau cordée
autonome enfin d'ailleurs pourquoi faire
avec qui pour quelle mission ça n'aurait
pas de sens en tout cas il est clair que
cette capacité à être leader elle est
aussi un dégage notre sécurité parce que
bien souvent un certain nombre
d'intérêts peuvent se traiter évidemment
à quelques centaines de kilomètres de
l'Hexagone voire plus y compris
outre-mer merci monsieur le ministre
pour le groupe horizon la parole est à
Yannick Favennec Beko merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre dans
l'entretien que vous avez accordé au
Monde en marge des annonces du président
de la République à Mont-de-Marsan vous
reveniez à la fois sur la question des
relocalisations de notre industrie
militaire et la possibilité d'acheter
sur l'étagère
certains armements auprès de nos
partenaires vous insistez sur le fait
que les achats sur l'étagère ne doivent
pas être un tabou dès lors qu'il y a des
conditions et que cela reste l'exception
vous indiquez notamment que l'urgence et
l'un des critères justifiant l'achat
d'armement directement opérationnel nous
l'avons fait pour les drones et nous
avons notamment passé commande de
sidrone Reaper américain en 2021
toutefois si l'enjeu de relocalisation
de notre BITD venait à se confirmer dans
une prochaine LPM pourriez-vous nous
préciser les critères les conditions
autre que l'urgence qui viendrait
justifier ces achats à l'étranger cela
est d'autant plus important que les
drones occupent une importance que nous
connaissons tous dans les nouveaux
développements technologiques souhaités
par le Président de la République dans
les prochaines années alors en attendant
l'eurodrome dont le programme de
développement a commencé en 2016 avec
l'Allemagne l'Espagne
peut-on s'attendre à des commandes
similaires à court terme et j'ai une
autre question si vous me le permettez
qui porte sur la dissuasion et sur le
nécessaire effort de communication
auprès de l'opinion en raison de
l'effort budgétaire significatif qui
sera accordé la LPM prévoit-t-elle
j'allais dire un volet pédagogique pour
expliquer la dissuasion et l'arsenal
français à nos concitoyens et davantage
expliciter l'articulation entre nos
forces conventionnelles et les forces
nucléaires je vous remercie
beaucoup Monsieur le Député bon moi le
principe c'est qu'on achète français
parce que ça fait partie du modèle aussi
de souveraineté d'autonomie stratégique
il y a pas de doute je vais même plus
loin c'est souvent méconnu mais vous
avez même des des capacités
produites par la bit des françaises qui
ne sont pas achetés par l'armée
française le VL mica ou les Godwin pour
donner cet exemple là sont de un exemple
de produits à l'export mais que la
marine n'a pas de godwing pour autant de
naval group exporte des gobelines bon ça
c'est un exemple mais ça dit aussi que
l'inverse est possible je dis parce que
souvent on ne dit pas assez 3 ça doit
vraiment rester d'exception en clair on
l'a fait pour les repères
je reviens pas sur la saga des drones
vous l'avez dit vous avez vous-même
signaler quelques programmes qui vont
être la solution dans les temps qui qui
vont venir
c'est vrai parfois des frappes en
profondeur regardez le LR2 dont on a
beaucoup parlé parce qu'on nous en avons
donné à l'Ukraine le ru n'est pas de
marque française et d'ailleurs le
remplaçant du et les Russes est plutôt
le high mars qui n'est pas non plus
français donc il y a toujours eu des
exceptions il y a toujours eu des
exceptions depuis le début la Cinquième
République mais dès lors qu'elles sont
contenues à l'exception ça doit être
évidemment la la norme étant entendu que
je n'identifie pas beaucoup d'exception
dans la période qui vient pour être
complètement honnête avec vous et vous
rassurer donc les donc les choses vont
bien dissuasion et pédagogie
pour moi très important il y a un
discours présidentiel par quinquennat le
Président vous l'avez noté il est revenu
au final un peu plus parce qu'il y a eu
l'école de guerre il est revenu sur la
dissuasion à Toulon il est revenu sur la
dissuasion à Mont-de-Marsan vendredi
dernier donc lui-même accélère sa prise
de parole sur la dissuasion nucléaire
alors que jadis on était sur un discours
cadre pour l'ensemble du septennat au du
quinquennat et circuler si j'ose dire là
il est clair que je pense que nos
opinions publiques ont besoin de
comprendre comment ça fonctionne que
notre doctrine elle est purement
défensive
en aucun cas elle ne saurait être
agressive que notre doctrine elle
protège nos intérêts vitaux qu'elle
rentre dans des critères qui sont très
précis menacent étatiques attribuable là
je ne fais que paraphraser le discours
du président mais je pense que sur la
base du discours du président
parlementaire au monde du gouvernement
on doit effectivement être capable
d'expliquer ce que ça veut dire quel est
l'héritage gaulien en la matière quels
sont les deux composantes enfin bon
après une dimension qui sont évidemment
plus confidentielles plus secrète mais
en tout cas la doctrine la manière dont
sa fonctionne est évidemment quelque
chose qui qui participe à notre
souveraineté qui doit trouver l'adhésion
de nos concitoyens et de des
contribuables aussi évidemment pour pour
financer pour financer cet effort en
tout cas je pense que moi je suis frappé
de mes tournées européennes quand on se
déplace en Grande-Bretagne ou sur le sol
national français on a des populations
qui sont inquiètes de ce qui se passe en
Ukraine et ce qui peut se passer avec la
Russie quand on va en Allemagne quand on
va en Pologne quand on va en gris quand
on va en République tchèque on a des
opinions publiques qui sont plus
qu'inquiètes qu'on peut parce que pour
le coup nous aussi nous avons quand même
intégré inconsciemment la dissuasion
comme étant évidemment un des grands
éléments de protection et pour cause
c'est le cas mais il est clair qu'il
faudra aussi faire cette pédagogie là on
pourra y revenir dans le cadre de la
programmation militaire en tout cas
président de la République souhaite
qu'il y ait une union la plus large
possible autour de cette question de la
dissuasion c'est ce que nous devons
aussi aux Grands Anciens compris les
bonnes décisions et c'est ce qu'on doit
aux générations futures pour le groupe
écologiste la parole est à Cyrielle
châtelain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre la guerre en Ukraine a mis en
avant nous lacunes dans plusieurs
domaines munitions artillerie Système
d'Informations de communication
renseignements plus encore et ça a été
dit elle a mis en évidence la faiblesse
des stocks il y a donc des besoins
cependant l'importance de l'augmentation
budgétaire annoncée nous questionne
notamment dans une période de crise
sociale et de crise climatique pour les
écologistes la solution pour assurer
notre sécurité dans un cas de budgétaire
durable et de s'appuyer davantage sur
l'Europe on pourrait penser par exemple
à des achats conjoints au niveau
européen ou à la création d'une chaîne
de production militaire européenne ce
qui serait assez révolutionnaire mais
les Européens produisent 178 systèmes
d'armes alors qu'aux États-Unis nous en
comptons 30 la Commission estime qu'on
peut économiser entre 25 et 100
milliards d'euros par an par une
meilleure coopération des États
européens et à ce stade on a quand même
un regret sur l'ambition en tout cas
affirmé par le président sur ce sujet de
mutualisation et de coopération
européenne de même cette augmentation
budgétaire nous questionne alors qu'on
assiste à une réforme du le corps
diplomatique qui vient couronner des
années de baisse drastique de budget
ayant pour objectif commun la paix
pensez-vous que celle-ci soit
atteignable si la politique française ne
fonctionne pas sur ces deux jambes
défense et diplomaties enfin j'aimerais
savoir c'est LPM comprendre des budgets
pour l'universalisation du sénu si oui
quel montant cela représenterait donc
quel objectif j'avoue que j'étais assez
interrogé voire interpellé du fait que
le SNU soit évoqué juste dans la suite
de l'augmentation de la réserve et avec
des propos du type disposé d'une
jeunesse parée à tous les pérides
monsieur le ministre
cool merci Madame présidente bon déjà
moi je suis si vous êtes déçu je vais
tenter de vous de vous rassurer sur les
mutualisations européennes tout à
l'heure le député que les coopérations
seraient dogmatiques ou idéologique non
je pense que pour le coup votre approche
comptable mais au sens noble du terme de
se dire qu'à plusieurs on peut faire
diminuer l'addition la Commission le
commissaire breton a documenté ça c'est
une réalité cette phase dite un B
jusqu'à 4 que la phase que les
industriels vont mener avant dites la
phase 2 qui va être la phase de
production cette phase AB quoi qu'il
arrive il nous aurait fallu la faire
l'affaire avec en franco-allemand et
avec les Espagnols qu'on oublie trop
souvent dans cette affaire c'est
évidemment aussi s'assurer d'une
soutenabilité budgétaire du programme et
j'aurais je l'espère quelques bonnes
nouvelles annoncées sur le Scaff aussi
dans les temps qui viendront même la
présidente sur d'autres pays qui
commencent à voir que le programme
avance et qui veulent le rejoindre donc
là aussi je pense qu'il faut être pers
différents sur cette affaire là vous
avez raison c'est qu'il aussi il faut
continuer de soutenir les instruments
d'achat vous savez dans le la présence
française d'un européenne à Versailles
les instruments d'achat commun et dire
pas etc ont été imaginés je pense qu'il
faut les faire vivre être capable
d'avoir l'ocar permet déjà de faire des
choses en matière d'innovation en tout
cas il faut le forcer parce que sinon
nous ne sommes condamnés de toute façon
à acheter sur étagère aux États-Unis ou
ailleurs donc le faire en européen c'est
le c'est l'assurance d'une souveraineté
c'est de fixer des emplois de la
richesse sur le territoire c'est un
meilleur bilan carbone et c'est aussi
faire diminuer la facture parce que
mutualisation de toute façon je pense
qu'il faut persévérer sur cette affaire
là deux jambes diplomaties armées vous
avez raison j'avais faiblesse de penser
que en tout cas j'espère que ce que nous
faisons si au sein du ministère des
armées aide nos diplomates à être
crédible aussi dans leur mission
quotidien en tout cas je vous
présenterai dans les semaines qui
viennent à un projet de renforcement de
nos missions de défense dans les
différentes ambassades puisque après
tout une ambassade dép mais après vous
avez des composantes qui peuvent
dépendre de Bovo ou de ou des armées ou
le cas échéant du ministère de la
Culture et donc je vais prendre ma part
sur les missions de défense pour
rehausser un certain nombre de postes
par reventilation d'ailleurs de postes
entre Paris et les ambassades parce que
je pense que là il y a un vrai besoin et
donc on va essayer aussi de
d'accompagner les modifications au sein
du corps diplomatique mais genre la
location d'y revenir et c'est nul je
suis pas sûr d'avoir le temps en un mot
le président voudra y revenir
il est clair qu'il y aura plusieurs
phases dans ce dans ce service national
universel et qu'à un moment donné il
faut aussi que nous on soit en capacité
donner de la visibilité pour je précise
bien que tout ça sur la base du
volontariat pour celles et ceux qui ont
ensuite voudront devenir réservistes ou
incorporer un certain nombre d'offres
pour la jeunesse que le ministère des
armées peut déjà avoir service militaire
volontaire etc mais aussi j'aurais
l'occasion de revenir devant vous
rétexuré dans le fera dans une session
je crois spécifique voilà même le
président merci monsieur le ministre
pour le groupe GDR la parole est à
Fabien Roussel là
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
la défense de la nation c'est
essentielle c'est la protection de nos
concitoyens dans les frontières de la
République comme à l'étranger c'est
protégé nos frontières notre
souveraineté alors oui oui pour mettre
l'accent sur le renseignement sur les
systèmes de défense entière aérien pour
nous protéger du terrorisme pour donner
les moyens à nos militaires d'exercer
leur mission pour produire en France et
soutenir notre industrie oui aussi pour
protéger défendre notre zone économique
exclusive en équipant notre marine
nationale qui patrouille dans cette zone
de 11 millions de kilomètres carrés où
vivent notamment nos concitoyens
d'outre-mer oui aussi pour se préoccuper
du spatial nous nous souhaitons que la
France comme d'autres pays d'ailleurs
continuent à s'engager contre les essais
de missiles antisatellites qui génère
des millions de débris mais
mais mais mais la loi de programmation
militaire va passer de 195 milliards
d'euros 2014 2019 à 413 milliards
d'euros pour la période à venir le
budget va donc passer de 32 milliards
d'euros par an à 59 milliards c'est 47%
de plus est quasiment le doublement du
budget des armées rien que la
modernisation de l'arme nucléaire rien
qu'elle va coûter 8 milliards d'euros
par an
alors Monsieur le Ministre d'abord ce
budget ne manquera pas d'interroger les
Français à qui votre gouvernement
demande des efforts notamment avec la
réforme des retraites en leur demandant
de travailler plus longtemps pour
trouver 12 milliards d'euros
mais surtout ce doublement du budget des
armées va participer risque de
participer à une course effrénée à
l'armement qui fait de l'Europe une
véritable poudrière nous observons une
Europe qui s'arme à outrance dans une
course voire même une concurrence
dangereuse entre État européen je fais
référence à l'Allemagne qui va devenir
la force qui rêve de devenir qui rêve de
devenir la force armée la mieux équipée
d'Europe et engage 100 milliards d'euros
sommes-nous en compétition avec
l'Allemagne c'est une spirale terrible
au sein de l'Europe dangereuse pour la
paix qui prend d'ailleurs le pas sur la
diplomatie
alors oui il faut réparer transformer
soigner notre défense nationale mais
n'allez-vous pas trop loin est-il
nécessaire de doubler le budget désarmé
alors que tant de besoins et d'attentes
s'expriment en France et que tant des
forces sont demandées aux Français ce
ministre oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
député merci pour la question parce que
je pense que le débat est noble et comme
il a parfois lieu de manière curieuse
sur les réseaux sociaux j'aime autant
qu'il ait lieu de manière posée
intellectuellement comme vous l'avez
fait dans le cadre de la commission bon
déjà vous donner acte vous-même à la
nécessité d'être présent sur beaucoup de
missions et vous le verrez en tout cas
je forme le vœu que que vous puissiez
m'en donner actuellement venu que
lorsqu'on va déplier les 413 milliards
d'euros vous verrez que les différentes
missions que vous avez listées vous-même
trouve une traduction rapide et donc
malheureusement c'est assez cher tout
simplement parce que aussi pour la
première fois les sauts technologiques
sont puissants la rapidité avec lesquels
il faut les faire sont puissants et
comme on vient de se dire sur plusieurs
orateurs qu'il faut en plus le faire en
européen ou en français
entre français par définition ça a un
prix et je pense que ça je j'appelle
aussi à une forme d'union sur cette
affaire c'est que ne pas acheter à Pékin
Moscou ou Washington un coup et c'est ce
qui explique aussi parfois on dit mais
comment se fait-il que dans telle ou tel
pays ils ont plus de matériel pour des
sommes différentes de nous etc tout
simplement aussi parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'industrie locale qu'il le font donc on
assume aussi ça et comme par ailleurs
vous êtes un défenseur de de l'emploi y
compris de l'emploi ouvrier dans un
certain nombre de bassins de nos
populations et de nos territoires je
pense que quand même ça pour le coup et
c'est ce qui d'ailleurs relié l’égoïstes
et les communistes dans les années 60
qui se sont divisés sur la diffusion
nucléaire sont divisées sur les
alliances mais ce sont retrouvés
notamment d'ailleurs aussi à l'époque
autour davantage des arsenaux que la BTD
en tant que tel donc ça je pense que il
faut qu'on l'assume sinon on dit pas la
vérité aux françaises aux Français sur
ce qu'il y a derrière les 413 milliards
d'euros en mission mais aussi on
souveraineté industrielle et là pour le
coup il faut qu'on soit évidemment
cohérent deux moi je respecte vos
opinions publiques faisons politiques
qui sont publiques et connus depuis les
années 60 sur la dysfaison nucléaire
nous ne sommes pas d'accord mais le
parti français constant sur cette
affaire ce qui d'ailleurs avait suscité
aussi de vivre de position dans les
années 60 et de stress c'est réitérer à
chaque fois de programmation militaire
vous êtes constant il y a pas de
surprise évidemment je respecte ces
convictions en étant pas d'accord mais
je le redis 3 je pense que notre
diplomatie est clair enfin à aucun
moment il y a une volonté de compétition
d'agressivité de la part de la France
au contraire quand il y a de
l'offensivité
elle est sur le terrain climatique même
si j'imagine que la présidente ou le
député Bayou nous dirait que ce n'est
pas assez mais en tout cas je ne peux
pas voir dans la diplomatie française
une volonté de rentrer en concurrence en
agressivité sur le terrain militaire ou
sécuritaire avec ton voisin contraire je
pense que puissance d'équilibre que nous
sommes on essaie parfois aussi de
rétablir dans des enceintes comme les
Nations Unies l'OTAN ou l'Union
européenne un multilatéralisme une prime
à la diplomatie le vrai sujet désormais
c'est la séparation du monde entre ceux
qui pensent que nous avons de vraies
menaces qui pèsent sur la nation
française et ceux qui considèrent au
fond que ces menaces sont virtuelles
c'est une vraie difficulté auquel je me
heurte pour être honnête avec vous
depuis que je suis ministre des armées
ou passer l'émotion du conflit en
Ukraine quand on dit mais faut mettre de
l'argent sur le cyber sur le spatial il
faut refaire les stocks de munitions je
vois bien que dans le regard certaines
personnes il y a vous n'en faites pas
assez on est en danger bougez-vous il y
a urgence et dans le regard de d'autres
personnes malgré tout mais pourquoi
redonner autant d'argent aux armées on
sait très bien au fond qu'on est protégé
par ailleurs on sait très bien que c'est
pas par la France que ça commencera etc
etc et ça je pense que cette clé de la
manière de travailler la LPM tous
ensemble c'est est-ce qu'on s'accorde au
moins sur les risques et sur les dangers
et merci d'avoir commencé par les
missions terrorisme etc parce que tout
d'un coup ça ça carène très très vite un
standard
enfin
de commentaires plus peut-être plus
politiques on peut pas attendre de nos
soldats un courage un vrai semblable si
on n'est pas au niveau sur la manière
dont on les accompagne et ça c'est aussi
le corps social français qui évolue et
donc l'acceptabilité de la militarité
elle passe aussi désormais par des
infrastructures qui sont sûrement en
meilleure état demain qu'il y a 20 ou 30
ans parce que sans doute qu'un jeune
soldat n'acceptera pas de vivre la même
chose que certains des anciens il y
avait ou 30 ans c'est vrai pour le
niveau technologique des armes parce
qu'elle suscite aussi une intérêt pour
le combattant donc si on demande
beaucoup à nos soldats on a aussi un
devoir d'équipement qui va en face tout
se tient et j'essaierai aussi de le
démontrer tout dernier point et vous ne
l'avez pas fait mais vous avez cité la
réforme des retraites un commentaire de
citoyens et de ministre des Armées je
pense qu'on a tort de poser les budgets
de la nation entre eux je vous rappelle
de voir vous augmentez vous n'avez ça je
le précise mais je l'ai vu sur les
réseaux sociaux
opposer le chiffre de la réforme des
retraites peu importe les convictions
politiques de chacun sur cette réforme
je la défends évidemment et le budget
des armées à mon avis c'est abîmer
l'acceptabilité sociétale et politique
de la Nation toute entière des efforts
que l'on fait pour nos soldats et pour
et pour notre politique de sécurité
commune c'est comme si d'autres
prenaient le budget du ce qu'on appelle
réel social ou du RSA et le comparerait
avec le budget des dépenses militaires
je pense que de là où nous sommes on
doit plutôt travailler à une forme
d'unité et opposer les budgets liés à la
réforme des retraites et le budget des
armées comme certains l'ont fait
récemment sur des radios ou des chaînes
de télévision ne me semble pas
utile au regard de ce que nous demandons
aux soldat par ailleurs merci monsieur
le ministre et enfin pour le groupe
pilote la parole est à Laurent panifaut
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre face aux enjeux qui nous
attendent ces prochaines années je tiens
à commencer ce propos en réaffirmant au
nom de mon groupe toute notre
reconnaissance et notre fierté à l'égard
de nos militaires qui assurent la
protection de notre état et de nos
concitoyens nous avons tous retenus un
chiffre clé des annonces du président de
la République plus de 400 milliards pour
la période 2024 2030 un effort massif
qui est proportionné au péril des
prochaines années je remarque que nos
voisins européens peut être encore plus
en retard que nous dans le chemin de la
reconstruction de leurs armées doivent
aujourd'hui amorcer des changements plus
brutaux à contrario pour nous cette
hausse s'inscrit dans la continuité d'un
travail mené depuis 2017 avec le soutien
de presque tous les groupes
parlementaires ce chiffre ne doit pas
pour autant cacher les défis multiples
et des failles persistantes
premier point sur la priorité donnée au
renforcement de notre souveraineté la
dissuasion nucléaire est souvent évoquée
mais elle ne suffit pas à elle seule
nous avons aussi de nombreux défis
capacitaires en termes de stock
notamment à l'heure des conflits à haute
intensité c'est un enjeu essentiel
comment la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire pourra-t-elle
nous permettre de reconstruire nos
stocks et d'accélérer les acquisitions
au-delà du chiffre global annoncé par le
président quels sont les moyens qui
seront annuellement consacrés au stock
de munitions et matériels notre BITD
peut-elle suivre ce rythme nos
industriels sont-ils en capacité
d'assurer de front livraison de matériel
pour nos armées et commandes pour les
payer étrangers autre ambition le
gouvernement entend renforcer la
coopération européenne et bilatérale
avec nos voisins en matière de défense
soyons réalistes la France peine
toujours à concrétiser cet objectif nous
avons célébré les 60 ans du traité de
l'Elysée mais les visions restent
divergentes avec l'Allemagne qui devrait
pourtant être un vrai partenaire en 2017
dans cette commission a été annoncée le
lancement de 5 grands projets d'armement
commun le résultat semble peu probant un
exemple le char du futur bloqué faute de
bonnes volonté de l'Allemagne mais aussi
de rivalités en tendustrielle de deux
pays inacceptable eu égard aux enjeux ce
ne sont pas des questions qui se règle
par des hausses de crédit concrètement
quand qu'allez-vous faire pardon pour
accélérer le pas de la défense
européenne évitez les blocages et
permettre à ces projets bilatéraux
d'aboutir autre point notre groupe porte
un intérêt particulier pour la question
des Outre-mer nos territoires
ultramarins sont particulièrement
exposés au conflit en particulier dans
l'océan Indien et dans le Pacifique pour
assurer les collectivités et les
citoyens ultramarins il nous faudra des
capacités de surveillance renforcées et
une certaine réactivité au niveau local
le président n'a pas donné de détails
sur ce point je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur Président
Monsieur le Député alors outre-mer il a
pas donné beaucoup de détails parce que
de lui-même a dit qu'il souhaitait le
faire lui-même dans un autre cadre et un
autre moment ça lui tient
particulièrement à cœur pour être très
honnête je pense que c'est un des grands
morceaux de particularité pivot de la
LPM qu'on va vous proposer parce que la
tyrannie des distances parce que les
menaces climatiques parce que les
menaces cyber ou hybrides
menacent chantage sur des flux
logistiques que sais-je évidemment son
propre à nos territoires
ultramarins et donc là je crois
qu'effectivement il nous faut une une
copie assez ambitieuse la détaille pas
maintenant mais sachez que ça ça doit
permettre au fond de rapprocher en d'un
point de vue tactique et logistique les
territoires d'outre-mer de l'Hexagone
c'est une capacité à projeter des moyens
opérationnels pour des missions des
entraînements de manière plus régulière
vous avez vous-même pitch black pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie pour prendre cet
exemple là pour l'armée de l'air il y a
d'autres des exemples évidemment pour la
marine et l'armée de terre en tout cas
il y a un tout autour de l'outre-mer qui
est clé et ça sera pas pour les
outre-mer ça sera une stratégie par
territoire d'outre-mer parce que la
Polynésie française c'est grand comme
l'Europe et donc c'est un sujet maritime
si on se pose des questions aussi sur
les nouvelles technologies il est
évident que les drones doit nous
apporter de solutions dans un territoire
aussi grand inversement la mission dite
harpie en Guyane correspond à d'autres
besoins militaires et une autre
coordination avec les forces de sécurité
intérieure la surveillance de nos eaux à
Mayotte aussi bref donc tout ça pour
dire que le président lui-même parce que
ça lui tient un véritablement à coeur
dans son ambition pour nos outre-mer et
donc on a évidemment l'occasion de dire
dans le détail défense européenne et en
partie déjà répondu de l'industrie des
coopérations des instruments
communautaires mais aussi de
l'opérationnel et ça je pense qu'il y a
des choses à faire mais j'ai déjà j'ai
déjà répondu sur les défis capacitaires
vous avez raison déjà de dire que c'est
le conventionnel qui tient la voûte
nucléaire
parfois aussi on a lu des choses un peu
étonnantes où on a voulu caricaturer des
propos que j'ai pas vraiment tenu mais
parfois des gens des problèmes
d'audition et donc le il est clair que
il ne peut pas y avoir de voûte
nucléaire si elle n'est pas soutenue par
une armée conventionnelle capacité aussi
à maîtriser l'escalade capacités aussi
tout simplement à protéger les
infrastructures de la dissuasion donc
pour plein de raisons évidemment c'est
important il est clair que la question
des stocks de munitions et clés et clé
mais il faut la regarder pour ce qu'elle
est je vois bien si on écoute aussi
certains commentateurs
peut-être qu'ils sont qu'il travaille
chez MBDA par ailleurs mais nous disent
qu'il faudrait pratiquement faire des
réassorts de stock digne de la guerre
froide pour avoir des hangars qui
seraient rempli de missiles ou de
munitions complexes ou non complexes non
il faut qu'on soit capable parce que
c'est l'argent du contribuable cette
affaire ici c'est pour chaque année
détruire des missiles parce que la date
de péremption est passée vous serez les
mêmes à venir dire au ministre et vous
aurez bien raison mais comment vous avez
géré votre affaire donc il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver une cible sur les
stocks de munitions qui correspond un
niveau d'entraînement de très bonne
qualité qui correspondent à un délai de
réactivité en cas d'engagement si le
fallait et c'est là après on reconnecte
avec l'économie de guerre entre le ratio
entre réactivité et endurance et je le
dis comme je le pense parce que c'est
l'argent du contribuable et qu'on en est
quand même redevable autant que je pense
qu'il faut avoir des stocks pour assumer
assurer entraînement assumer assurer
réactivité c'est là après il y aura un
débat dans la LPM avec le rapport annexé
les contrats opérationnels quel est le
degré d'épaisseur de cette réactivité
que le Parlement va attendre pour nos
armées très bien en revanche sur
l'endurance c'est là où il faut
solliciter l'économie de guerre et c'est
après aux entreprises d'être capable de
monter en puissance sur sur la capacité
à produire s'il nous fallait tenir en
tout cas c'est ce que je vous proposerai
dans l'alpm qui me semble être la bonne
ligne de répartition merci Monsieur le
Ministre alors il nous reste environ 25
minutes et 16 questions je propose donc
que chaque intervenant se limite à une
minute on va laisser ministre un peu
respirer et il dis une dizaine de
minutes pour répondre à l'ensemble de
ces 16 questions la parole est à
Jean-Michel Jacques
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'aimerais évoquer avec vous le
concept de défense opérationnelle du
territoire face à toutes les crises
majeures sur notre territoire national
les armées sont en mesure de participer
à la gestion de crise avec une grande
réactivité et dans le cadre d'un
dialogue civil militaire confronté je
vous citerai par exemple et entre autres
le déploiement de l'opération sentinelle
face au terrorisme de l'opération
résilience durant le covid ou
l'engagement de nos armées face aux
incendies l'été dernier
et tout cela on est la preuve il est
indiqué dans la revue stratégique
nationale stratégique que le concept de
défense opérationnelle du territoire
serait rénovée quels sont les axes
majeurs à la transformation de ce
concept pour répondre au mieux aux
nouveaux enjeux sécuritaires merci la
parole est à Franck je l'ai dit
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'ai deux questions depuis
2021 le taux de disponibilité technique
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre équipement
disponible et pack total des équipements
militaires français c'est-à-dire le seul
indicateur qui permet de savoir combien
d'équipements sont réellement
disponibles et confidentiels or
l'approche de l'examen de la prochaine
loi de programmation la représentation
nationale aurait souhaité connaître la
marge de manœuvre dont elle disposée
quant à sa participation dans la
construction de cette loi en effet pour
qu'il puisse les différer il est
nécessaire que le parlementaire soit en
mesure de s'appuyer sur des informations
fiables et précises or nous ne pouvons
que nous étonner de l'absence de
communication mais surtout de l'absence
et on en a déjà évoqué dans ces
commissions de réponses faites au
parlementaire qui se mettent des
questions écrites au Gouvernement sur ce
sujet donc dès lors monsieur le ministre
pensez-vous apporter une réponse aux
questions écrites qui vous ont été
soumis sur ce sujet avant l'examen de la
loi enfin par ailleurs dans les vœux
qu'il adressait aux armées vendredi
dernier et en l'occurrence à l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace le président a
indiqué vouloir passer au interface
d'ici 2030 très bien mais dans ce cas
monsieur le ministre permettez-moi de
relever une petite incohérence si tel
est vraiment l'objectif pourquoi
concentrer des moyens du temps et une
partie du budget à la rénovation de 55
mirages 2000 pour rappel j'en faisais
état dans mon rapport budgétaire le
premier mirage rénové n'a été livré
qu'en 2021 et les livraisons prévus
c'est à jusqu'en 2025 merci en tout
rafale implique le retrait de toute la
flotte je propose à chacun de se
concentrer sur une question si possible
la parole est à Martine Étienne
et Monsieur le Ministre le service de
santé des armées a été victime d'une
austérité criminelle lors des précédents
mandats et continue aujourd'hui à
souffrir de restrictions budgétaire de
fermeture d'établissements et d'un
manque de personnel criant renforcé par
l'intensification des conflits lors des
débats sur le PLF 2023 vous avez affirmé
à mon collègue Aurélien Saintoul vouloir
suspendre les opérations importantes de
restructuration du SSR en cours mais il
semblerait que la fermeture de
lithia des jeunettes de Lyon sont
aujourd'hui confirmés alors avez-vous
menti ou ne vous ne savez simplement pas
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
concernant la LPM soyez soyez sûr que
nous agirons pour l'augmentation des
moyens du SSA pour qu'il prenne en
compte les nouveaux modes de conflit
qu'il puisse prendre en charge
l'ensemble des biaissets psychiques et
pour que la procédure d'octroi d'une
pension d'indemnité suite à ce type de
blessure soit simplifié vous avez vous
avez d'ailleurs dit que vous y étiez
favorable nous ne pouvons que nous en
réjouir nous avions d'ailleurs fait une
proposition de loi sur la simplification
des la procédure d'octroi lors du
précédent mandat enfin concernant les
retraites des militaires j'aimerais
obtenir une clarification souhaitez-vous
vraiment aujourd'hui demander aux
militaires déjà auprès éprouvé par des
conflits de plus en plus intenses de
travailler deux ans de plus pour une
retraite complète sans parler de
retraite des conjoints des conjointes de
militaires donc je rappelle les règles
si possible pour se limiter chacun à une
minute et une question si possible la
parole est à jeudi poteau
oui merci Michel le président monsieur
le ministre ma question marque une
double actualité celle de la préparation
de la LPM et celle de la réforme des
retraites elle porte plus précisément
sur la situation des conjointes de
militaires dont la carrière des pains
pour la plupart d'entre elles de la
carrière du soldat vous allez me dire si
je me trompe mais d'après des chiffres
dont j'ai eu connaissance 73% des femmes
de militaires sont en activité mais
elles le connaissent des carrières en
pointillés et très souvent des
changements de caisse d'assurance ceux
qui ne simplifier rien en cause les
mutations régulières de l'époux plus de
30000 militaires ont muté en 2020 et 37%
des conjointes de militaires ne
retrouvent pas d'emploi un an après la
mutation si dans ce contexte les
perspectives de carrière sont plus
limitées pour les femmes de militaires
comme l'a montré l'Observatoire des
conjoints du ministère des armées il
faut aussi retenir que les conjointes
sont souvent contraintes de travailler à
temps partiel pour combler l'absence du
papa et organiser la vie de famille avec
les enfants dans cette catégorie de la
population le taux de part à la retraite
avec une carrière incomplète et de 44%
je ne pense pas que la réforme des
retraites prennent en compte cette
difficulté monsieur le ministre selon
vous alors que la suggestion de nos
militaires impactent lourdement la vie
personnelle et professionnelle des
conjointe pensez-vous que la loi LPM
serait le meilleur outil
allez merci j'attends
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un modèle complet mais pas
comme avant vous m'avez tendu la perche
dans votre Limère on évoquant les
caisses et les cantines et évoquant les
séné-le alors je voudrais revenir sur le
sujet des infrastructures qui est un
sujet qui me paraît absolument majeur
pour cette future loi de programmation
militaire vous avez évoqué en creux
évoquant les cantines la question des
externalisations ou en tout cas d'une
partie de service qui pourrait être
opérée différemment
que prévoit en termes d'infrastructure
qu'est-ce qui devrait selon vous faire
l'objet d'évolution d'externalisation
quel rôle vous voyez pour le SID dans
les années qui viennent
et puisque nous parlions sous-marin et
que je n'ai pas encore coulé la minute
monsieur le Président
entendez-vous accorder le titre de
reconnaissance de la nation au
submariniers qui ont plongé abordé et
c'est né le sujet récurrent et sur
lequel Alphos s'est exprimé récemment je
vous remercie merci la parole est à
Benoît Borda
ça allait pas bien excusez-moi monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre j'ai
raccourci ma question à nous de vont
être en capacité de dissuader tout État
ou organisation de prendre le risque de
frapper notre territoire national
d'autant que des groupes terroristes au
vu de la baisse des coûts des drones et
des missiles peuvent nous souder nous
cibler avec une facilité qui était
impensable il y a quelques années en
conséquence le président a donc annoncé
avec la future loi de programmation
militaire une hausse de 50% du budget de
la défense solaire alors malgré le temps
qu'il nous reste si vous pouvez nous
détailler à plus précisément les enjeux
et les détails de cette augmentation je
vous remercie
merci la parole est à Julien rend cool
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais vous interroger
sur le budget à louer aux munitions dans
le cadre de la LPM à venir en tant que
cours rapporteur de la mission flash sur
les stocks de munitions avec notre
collègue Vincent Bru j'ai pu interroger
tous les acteurs concernés les
militaires les industriels et des
chercheurs spécialistes du sujet le
constat est sans appel notre stock de
munitions est actuellement family les
industriels nous ont confirmé attendre
chaque jour de nouvelles commandes
nous devons être à la hauteur de
l'ambition de nos discours et la
question des munitions ne doit pas être
une doit pas être une variable
d'ajustement de nos budgets militaires
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer donc le la part du budget que
vous comptez consacrer aux munitions
pour les années à venir éventuellement
vous en avez brièvement parlé
pouvez-vous nous aussi nous donner plus
de détails sur l'achat de munitions
rodeuses que vous prévoyez pour la LPM
et enfin pourriez-vous nous dire si vous
envisagez de relocaliser une filière de
petite de munitions de petits calibres
en France pour garantir à l'avenir notre
souverain souveraineté dans le domaine
je vous remercie la parole est à Fabien
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre j'étais ravi de vous accueillir
sur ma circonception dans les Landes
pour ces annonces il faisait pas froid
non pour ces annonces sur la future LPM
je reviendrai pas sur la densité
stratégique du discours du président ça
a été largement évoqué
mais vous savez donc vous étiez dans les
Landes et dans les Landes c'est le
département de France on le produit le
plus de pétrole sur le territoire
français vous voyez venir 1% de nos
besoins 1% de nos besoins sont produits
sur le sol français et les armées
consomment 1% de nos besoins vous parlez
tout à l'heure des inquiétudes sur
l'évolution du baril du Brent notamment
pour nos OPEX moi je vous parle de
pétrole stratégique et de pétrole
stratégique responsable sachant qu'il y
a trois fois moins d'émission carbone
sur du pétrole qui est extrait en France
plutôt que celui qui est importé
quelle perspective par rapport au
pétrole français après 2040 sachant que
ça mériterait un assouplissement de la
loi Hulot mais dans un esprit tout à
fait responsable merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci la parole est à Loïc
prud'homme
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre lors des discussions
budgétaires au mois d'octobre et alors
que je vous interrogez via un collègue
sur un amendement que j'avais posé sur
l'avenir de l'hôpital d'instruction des
armées Robert Picqué ou mentionné la
suspension des opérations en cours
autour du service de santé des armées en
attendant l'obtention d'un état des
lieux aujourd'hui on nous discutons de
la construction de la loi de
programmation militaire où en êtes-vous
de l'état des lieux du SSA pouvons vous
pouvons-nous aujourd'hui nous passer
d'un service de risque nrbt dans
notamment ce que contient l'hôpital
militaire Robert Picqué et puis
pouvons-nous aussi nous passer des
recettes que vous mentionnez tout à
l'heure les recettes budgétaires qui
sont apportées par par ces hôpitaux
militaires j'ai sollicité une entrevue
avec vous pour partager 6 ans de travail
parlementaire et de terrain sur cette
établissement j'espère que nous pourrons
l'organiser bientôt afin que vous ayez
une vue assez complète et en dehors
peut-être des des présentations
peut-être un petit peu tronquées qui
pourraient vous être fait des des gens
du locaux qui ont des intérêts parfois
un petit peu troubles merci la parole
est à Delphine lingleman
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre plus que jamais aux côtés de la
dégéa notre BITD le pivot de la nouvelle
économie de guerre pour garantir la
souveraineté militaire de la France nous
devons donc accompagner tous nos
industriels de la défense dans leur
diversité pour répondre aux défis de
produire plus vite en grande quantité il
y a des prix soutenables la prochaine
LPM soutiendra ce changement de
paradigme l'outil industriel existe le
savoir-faire aussi à l'instar de
certaines entreprises situées histoire
dans le Puy-de-Dôme Constellium ou
encore brencube qui grâce à des
technologies dia permet aux industriels
d'optimiser leur gestion de production
fin de répondre aux objectifs de notre
économie de guerre la prochaine LPM
devra donc prendre en compte également
les problématiques de l'abbitd l'érosion
de certains savoir-faire scientifiques
et technologiques la tension sur les
ressources humaines la difficulté
d'approvisionnement sur certaines
matières premières et composants et je
finirai par la lourdeur administrative
des marchés publics en tant que membre
du groupe de travail dédié à l'économie
de guerre que vous avez installée et qui
fonctionne en bonne intelligence il me
tenait à cœur de vous interroger avec le
sur le soutien apporté à l'habilité des
en ce sens pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre apporter une réponse sur
certains de ces points notamment en
dressant en étain des lieux des
commandes publiques à venir en France et
au niveau des programmes européens par
ailleurs merci merci
s'il vous plaît une seule question la
parole est alisiade métayée
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre donc comme vous le savez
peut-être je suis rapporteur d'une
mission d'information flash sur les
fonds marins que nous vous présenterons
par ailleurs très bientôt donc le
ministère des armées à publier en
février 2022 une stratégie pour les
fonds marins dans celle-ci il était
prévu l'achat de deux drones pour les
3000 mètres et de deux drones pour les
6000 mètres toutefois de plus en plus
d'acteurs s'intéressent à ce milieu les
menaces se sont dernièrement accrues sur
nos câbles de télécommunication sur nos
ressources naturelles également sur
notre dissuasion vous avez évoqué dans
vos propos liminaires la nécessité de
prendre de l'avance sur la maîtrise des
fonds marins monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous détailler la part que
représentera cette stratégique dans la
prochaine LPM je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Philippe serez
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre durant son discours aux armées
le chef de l'État a insisté à juste
titre sur la nécessité d'un pivot vers
la haute intensité comme vous le savez
dans un contexte de guerre de haute
intensité conservez la supériorité
informationnelle et primordiale
c'est d'autant plus vrai que des
ruptures technologiques sont déjà à
craindre de la part de nos compétiteurs
en avance certaines innovations telles
que l'informatique quantique ou
l'intelligence artificielle monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous préciser les
contours d'une augmentation des crédits
en faveur du champ en formationnel et
plus largement de la guerre du numérique
de plus à l'aune de l'actualité au
Burkina Faso pour nous être confiant à
la capacité de notre pays à combler ses
lacunes s'agissant de la lutte contre
les campagnes de désinformation merci la
parole est à Jean-Philippe ardent
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre dans un contexte international
troublé la future loi de programmation
militaire sera ambitieuse et inédite
c'est un véritable signal envoyé à nos
forces armées pour le maintien du statut
de la France à l'international et pour
notre souveraineté vendredi 20 janvier
lors de ses vœux aux armées le président
de la République annoncé vouloir doubler
à terme le nombre de réservistes
opérationnels nous savons l'importance
des réserves pour nos armées pour notre
territoire national et pour le lien
armée nation monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous préciser le budget
qui sera plus spécialement consacré aux
réserves et quelles évolutions
envisagez-vous pour les réservistes tant
pour le nombre d'heures de services que
pour les missions qui leur seront
confiées dans l'avenir je vous remercie
merci la parole est à Christophe
Blanchet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
je reviens sur les réserves j'ai eu la
chance de participer au groupe de
travail au 6 réunions le groupe de
travail sur les réserves et quand on
faisait pas la politique de la chaise
vue on arrivait à faire des conclusions
et des propositions la preuve s'y
accueille 150 propositions sur ses 150
positions je reviendrai sur l'une
d'entre elles sur le lien R1 R2 et sur
le fait que le R2 sont souvent pas
identifiés par reconnu et pas appelé
parce que on ne sait pas où elles sont
donc qu'est-ce que vous avez une
disposition là-dessus particulière pour
mieux construire là-dessus sur la RO1 et
RO2 et deuxième question puisque j'ai le
temps monsieur le Président je
reviendrai sur votre réponse sur le s&u
pour une précision le s&i aujourd'hui ce
sont deux phases obligatoires dans le
temps c'est la phase numéro 1 et la
phase numéro 2 dans votre réponse il y a
une précision sur la face numéro 2 vous
diriez qu'elle serait facultative or la
volonté au Président c'est qu'elle soit
obligatoire mais à travers votre réponse
et que ce serait pas que la phase numéro
2 puissent
facilitante pour celles et ceux des
jeunes qui voudraient aller vers les
armées en laissant le choix
éventuellement de continuer d'aller vers
des missions d'intérêt général telles
qu'elle est aujourd'hui merci et enfin
la parole est à Sabine merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre il y a un
chapitre dans la revue nationale
stratégique qui concerne la résilience
la résilience de notre société donc on
parle beaucoup là dans la LPM de la
résilience de nos armées mais en fait la
résilience de nos sociétés en cas de
conflit ou en cas de problématique
qu'est-ce qui est prévu dans la LPM
est-ce que quelque chose y est prévu
effectivement on parle beaucoup de
l'éducation des jeunes il y a des
classes défenses il y a les CNU il y a
tout un tas de dispositifs mais est-ce
qu'il y aura un volet
spécifique résilience de notre société
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup je
commence par la fin pour résilience par
définition c'est d'ailleurs le mot est
très utilisé peut-être un peu trop
désormais
on pourrait aussi parler de simplement
de résistance dans durant donc je pense
que ça vaut le coup de le définir parce
que comme médiatiquement il est employé
très régulièrement je peux pas dire
qu'il est abîmé mais en tout cas il peut
correspondre à des sens qui sont pas
forcément ceux que on pourrait toujours
attendre ou entendre je pense que ce que
ma programmation militaire doit pouvoir
faire et je le dis aussi humblement
devant les différentes représentations
politiques ici à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est déjà créé l'unité
c'est ce qu'on est capable de créer de
l'unité sur les questions de défense
dans l'hémicycle lorsqu'on va voter une
LPM je le dis parce que j'ai donné
l'exemple des années 60 pas forcément
partie bien droit depuis il y a quand
même une capacité à créer du consensus
autour de ça c'est quand même la
première des sujets deuxième des sujets
on parle beaucoup du lien
arménation moi j'aime bien d'ailleurs
plutôt nation armée comme si je pense
que c'est plus dans ce sens là que les
choses peuvent se présenter et qu'il
éclaire que tout ce que l'on va faire
pour travailler sur le lien nation armée
va dans le bon sens d'où mon propos tout
à l'heure de réponse au député Roussel
si la somme devient
comment dire un argument politique pour
dire c'est trop enfin au bout d'un
moment soit on repart des menaces soit
on repart pas des menaces et donc faut
créer aussi du consensus autour de cette
affaire là pareil sur les sujets liés au
SMU pareil sur les sujets de réserve
pareil sur des sujets qui existent déjà
le service militaire adapté en outre-mer
le SMV etc donc je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de les raisins citoyennes il y
a mille sujets qui permettent de
travailler évidemment sur cette
résidence je remets des guillemets et
c'est nul de fait en fait on parle pas
de la même chose
moi je suis déjà dans la projection de
ce que pourrait être la phase
optionnelle militaire proposée par le
minable en lien avec les réserves je
l'ai appelé phase 2 parce que la pâte
non encore mais encore pas la phase 1
c'est ça que je voulais dire pour être
agréable héro 2 et budget budget les
sommes seront là tout simplement
dès lors que l'on Karen a un ratio de 2
pour un il va sans dire derrière qu'on
doit avoir les budgets pour convoquer
les budgets pour habiller et les budgets
pour accueillir genre l'occasion de le
détailler mais il est clair qu'ils
d'ailleurs quelque chose me dit que les
obstacles à la convocation sont pas
forcément budgétaires
quelques fois en tout cas dans ma vie de
réserviste par ailleurs j'ai pu le
constater on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
héro deux c'est un beau sujet voilà un
sujet en plus qui est méconnu de la
plupart de nos concitoyens je rappelle
que les retraités de l'arme doivent 5
ans de réserves obligatoires aux forces
armées et que ils peuvent être rappelés
dans le code de la défense à n'importe
quel moment par décision du commandement
du ministre d'ailleurs ou dans une autre
mesure du président de la République en
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui cette
obligation il faudrait la faire vivre ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui pour être
très direct ou que dans des unités très
particulières pour des fonctions très
particulières mais ce n'est pas du tout
généraliste ou généralisé et donc moi je
vous proposerai dans le cadre du des
conclusions du GT réserve que j'aurai
l'occasion de revoir prochainement merci
pour le travail qui a été fait
d'ailleurs par les associations les
parlementaires les élus les syndicats
aussi beaucoup de travail a été faits
produits sur cette affaire j'aurais
l'occasion de y revenir mais il est
clair que peut-être que la capacité à
mieux tracer l'aéro2 dans la durée
euh va être clé notamment aussi quand il
y a un changement d'adresse quand un
militaire qui est parti en retraite qui
soit capable avec les outils désormais
digitaux de signaler tout simplement que
là il a changé d'adresse parce qu'ils
sont portables etc ça nous permet
évidemment de garder si cette terreau en
tout cas il faudra qu'on en reparle la
copine est pas sèche parce que pour le
coup moi je suis en discuter avec le GT
pour voir un peu ce qu'on va mettre dans
la programmation militaire dans la
partie normative sur cette affaire là je
remonte en accélérant
fond marin il est clair que il y a des
priorités de protection de nos
infrastructures sous-marines ça te dit
pour les câbles c'est vrai aussi pour
les pipelines ou tout ce qui permet de
faire circuler un 70 au carmure il y a
une copie importante sur la guerre des
mines parce qu'on voit bien que c'est un
sujet pour demain sur les bâtiments
hydrographiques et puis le président de
l'a dit sur les moyens qui permet
vraiment d'aller en grande profondeur
notamment assimile mètres on aura
l'occasion de détailler cette affaire
j'ai pas le temps en seulement quelques
secondes mais en tout cas la
contribution du Parlement et de votre
mission sera évidemment plus que la
bienvenue parce que ça va nous permettre
de solidifier aussi une stratégie là
aussi sur ce sujet qu'est ce qu'on une
personne qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire à
plusieurs notamment en Atlantique ou en
Méditerranée quand on est pas loin de
nos côtes en lien avec les Britanniques
en lien avec les Italiens avec les
espagnols les portugais se sont
évidemment des questions importantes sur
le soutien la BITD bon je la faiblesse
de penser que cette copie et la
visibilité qui va être donnée est déjà
un grand soutien non là où en revanche
je pense qu'on doit pouvoir importer un
autre soutien et je n'ai pas assez dit
simplification des normes y compris au
sein de la DGA moins de papier
ne fera pas de mal et au sein des armées
une simplification de l'expression de
besoin
vous avez un chat enfin vous avez un
canon César assis roux à huit roues
enfin bon on s'aperçoit que tout d'un
coup évidemment tout ça pas facile si
vous voulez standardiser accélérer c'est
que mieux d'avoir standardisé
précisément donc là évidemment le vrai
soutien aussi ne sera pas que financier
il va aussi passer par la manière de
commander donc ça ça fait partie du
mandat que j'ai confié au DGA ce matin
service de santé des armées vous y êtes
revenu l'un et l'autre et je vous en
remercie non je ne mens pas Madame la
député d'ailleurs je me permettrai pas
de dire que vous vous mentez le mot est
violent et c'est ça on se les dit dans
l'hémicycle et je vous remercie
d'ailleurs pour l'attention que vous
avez parce que c'est un beau service et
on sait qu'il a été abîmé parce que dans
les coupes budgétaires de cette dernière
année c'est vraiment l'infrastructure de
soutien avec le scan dans une autre
mesure mais mais qui ont véritablement
c'était difficile je veux dire pour pour
les forces engagées dans le service de
santé des armées moi j'ai décidé de tout
remettre à plat ce qui est vrai des
infrastructures en province est vrai des
infrastructures ou des personnels que
l'on peut envoyer c'est particulièrement
vrai aussi de Bégin et persil dans leur
capacité à assumer des situations
dégradées vous pouvez avoir une pandémie
type covid plus un attentat de masse
plus une corde de soldats préparé à un
engagement plus enfin vous
malheureusement dans un dessin très
dégradé vous pouvez avoir nos deux
grands hôpitaux parisiens militaires
très sollicité et c'est vrai aussi
évidemment pour les hôpitaux régionaux
donc moi je reviendrai vers vous avec
une copie service de santé des armées
dont je vous le dis évidemment les
moyens vont être en augmentation cela va
sans dire façon on peut pas continuer
comme cela au-delà des mesures Ségur etc
j'entends c'est-à-dire que avoir une
copie aussi plus militaire du SSA sur
ses missions ça c'est aussi clé je donne
un exemple très concret les traumas
psychiques psychiatriques il y a peu
d'armées qui désignent des moyens en
Recherche et Innovation pour traiter les
blessures psychiques des soldats bah ça
typiquement soit on aide le SSA à
continuer sur ses fonctions là et on
pourra avancer soit on réduit trop les
moyens évidemment on prendra du retard
et les infras monsieur député vous avez
raison la copie prévoit aussi une
augmentation importante sur les infras
mais je vous en ferai peut-être un focus
spécifique sur SSR parce que à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat et je crois
quelque soit les sensibilités politiques
il y a une volonté de d'avoir une belle
ambition pour le service de santé des
armées c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai un
peu retenu la copie telle qu'elle était
partie je l'avais dit dans l'hémicycle
parce que moi je veux qu'on ait une
vision globale sur cette affaire donc je
leur ai dit d'ailleurs pour les services
sur les hydrocarbures les Landes bien
connues pour son pétrole et son et son
bois
c'est le SGDSN qui a pris la main sur
sur ce dossier il est interministériel
il pose effectivement des questions sur
notre droit en matière d'accès énergie
je pense que c'est un sujet qui peut
être sensible aussi par par les temps
qui courent donc il faut le circonscrire
moi je suis pas le ministre décisionnel
sur cette affaire en tout cas je sais
que vous êtes un avocat qui vous
déployez beaucoup sur ce dossier vous en
avez parlé vous même au présent de la
République vendredi dernier vous avez
saisi un certain nombre de ministères et
c'est suite d'ailleurs à vos saisies de
Monsieur le Député que le
d'instruire les choses donc je vous en
remercie pour l'engagement vous avez et
pour votre territoire et pour réfléchir
à l'autonomie à l'autonomie énergétique
des armées dans une des solutions
dégradées pour le carburant opérationnel
donc c'est un sujet évidemment qu'on va
regarder munition monsieur le député
je reviens pas sur ce que j'ai dit
je reviens pas sur ce que j'ai pu dire
sur réactivité versus endurance parce
que je vois bien sinon c'est le
contribuable qui va payer 15 ans de
stock quoi bon donc faut quand même être
raisonnable donc c'est là où il faudra
qu'on vous fera des propositions pour
trouver le bon équilibre première chose
mission rodeuse merci d'en parler parce
que pour le coup c'est clé j'aurais
l'occasion de détailler la copie mais je
vais vous répondre quand même
directement maintenant notre horizon
2030 dans la LPM c'est d'en avoir
plusieurs milliers donc une vraie
ambition sur les munitions rodeuse c'est
aussi un des vrais rétex pour l'Ukraine
donc plutôt que de faire des stocks de
manière indifférenciée on va aussi
s'intéresser à la nature même des
systèmes d'armes pour regarder ce dont
on peut avoir besoin en fonction de la
nature de l'engagement la réactivité que
l'on doit avoir et l'endurance est-ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
défense solaire c'est un sujet
qui mérite un détail précis parce que là
aussi toutes les couches ne se valent
pas l'exode atmosphérique n'est pas la
lutte antidrone du quotidien or on a
besoin de couvrir toutes les couches je
vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui avec avec
le mistral ou avec un certain nombre de
techniques ou de capacité ou de matériel
on est capable de tenir la courte portée
il y a évidemment la courte slash
moyenne portée notamment les crottages
qui sont des ombres bien connus
d'ailleurs je signale à la
représentation nationale que quasiment
tous les tirs de crotale en Ukraine
contre des missiles russes sont des tirs
réussis donc les Ukrainiens nous l'ont
dit et ça c'est comme une satisfaction
une fois de plus de donner du matériel
qui fonctionne bien qui est employable
et qui permet aux soldats Ukrainiens
d'avoir une protection effective de qui
a fait de sa région donc ça je pense
qu'il faut quand même le souligner les
grottes on va les retirer petit à petit
au profit notamment Devel Mika la cité
déjà tout à l'heure c'est pour la courte
moyenne portée puis évidemment vous avez
la grande portée on connaît le américain
en franco-italien ça s'appelle le santé
NG c'est à peu près le même niveau de
technologie le santé Mamba et on va vers
une version nouvelle génération NG que
je l'aurai l'occasion de vous présenter
dans la nouvelle VPN très clairement la
défense solaire a été une fonction
négligée ces 15 dernières années pour
tout un tas de raisons et c'est un des
efforts majeurs de LPM y compris en
chiffre
en milliard d'euros tout à fait clair
c'est indispensable pour plein de
raisons que le Président de la
République a détaillé vendredi dernier
donc je n'y reviens pas mais enfin
évidemment l'occasion de d'en reparler
devant vous sur le taux de disponibilité
des matériels monsieur le député
génétique bon faut qu'on trouve une
solution j'assume le secret grand public
parce qu'en fait c'est une donnée dans
tes friands nos compétiteurs je me cache
pas de la réalité c'est ça donne
véritablement la disponibilité réelle de
nos armées avec parfois dans une semaine
à l'autre ça peut varier parce que bon
donc moi je vais donner mandat et
peut-être qu'on réfléchisse en lien le
président gassiou parce que pour le coup
je peux pas priver la présentation
nationale aussi de la transparence
nécessaire sur cette affaire il faut
peut-être qu'on trouve le moyen d'avoir
une communication sécurisée de cette
affaire avec quelques engagement de
confidentialité bon voilà en tout cas
moi je veux rien vous cacher mais je
veux qu'on assume collectivement le fait
que c'est une donnée qu'on ne donne pas
à ceux qui n'aiment pas la France pour
faire très vite je vous réponds tout de
goût donc ça évidemment il faut le il
faut le trouver tout rafale alors il y a
plusieurs types de mirage là aussi sinon
on fait une grosse saucisse de tout et
on comprend plus
c'est le mirage 2000- c'est que nous
allons retirer progressivement de de la
circulation avec un pivot vers le Rafale
et donc tout ce qui est confirmé sur le
Mirage 2000 T et toujours d'actualité je
vous présenterai des courbes de pivot
c'est c'est une un effort énorme qui
tient aussi compte des capacités de
production d'assaut sans retarder
l'exportation donc là aussi il faut
qu'on mais le type il y a plus de stress
on est sur une flotte de chasse
désormais qui est bien standardisée dans
les contrats opération sont connus il y
a plus de tension comme par le passé
donc le la DGA va discuter avec Dassault
pour permettre justement d'avoir une
trajectoire progressive on assume le
pivot du Tour rafales comme le dit le
président de la République parce que il
faut avoir conscience mais vous le savez
parce que vous avez tenu le crayon pour
le rapport c'est que plus vous avez de
type d'avions différents plus vous
multipliez du MCO et avec un MCO sur les
mirages qui coûtent de plus en plus cher
les années durant et passant donc là le
pivot à la fois coûte un peu d'argent ça
permettra de continuer à répondre au
députés Roussel et aux autres coûte un
peu d'argent parce que ça permettra
aussi de réduire les MCO ensuite sur les
années qui suivront donc ça aussi il
faudra le documenter et l'expliquer à la
présentation nationale en tout cas
l'esprit de la manœuvre si j'ose dire
elle est là elle va être discuter avec
les uns et les autres et enfin je
termine par le député Jean-Michel
Jacques sur la défense opérationnelle du
territoire ah non je vais obliger de
parler de pardonnez-moi tout le volet
femme de militaire etc non mais il me
répond pas non après
après vous reconnaîtrez que la séance de
questions crible et redoutable quand
même donc vous me pardonnerez vous serez
preuve d'indulgence non le plan famille
j'ai peur non le plan famille doit nous
permettre de traiter au-delà de ce qui
est prévu dans la forme des retraites
j'y reviens pas mais le plan family nous
permet d'avoir des choses encore plus
ambitieux sur les conjoints des
conjoints moi je pense que
l'homme est la député Santiago vous êtes
quelques-uns et une à y être revenu dans
les groupes de travail il est clair que
le plan famille 1 Florence parlait à
décider il y a mis beaucoup de cœur un
engagement a permis de faire bouger des
lignes il y a deux trois je l'ai déjà
dit publiquement je le redis ce micro il
y a deux trois
segments fonctions qui n'ont pas
suffisamment été peut-être traités en
lien avec les collectivités
territoriales les enfants en bas âge les
crèches et les conjoints voilà je veux
pas tout détailler mais il est clair que
il faut que ça soit pris en compte et
vous avez raison on peut pas parler de
fidélisation on peut pas parler de
militarité on va parler de
d'acceptabilité du flux de mutation
ministère des armées films ok il y a
plus de plus de plus de mutation dans la
République bon pour tout ça soit
acceptable bien vécu socialement il y a
donc des pré-requis et votre question
évidemment va dans ce sens de ces
prérequis qu'il faut traiter député
Jean-Michel Jacques
défense opérationnelle du territoire bon
le soleil était ce que je viens de
développer sur le solaire est évidemment
un des morceaux ce que je viens de
développer sur l'outre-mer est un des
autres grands morceaux et en fait on
voit de plus en plus que les contrats
opérationnels entre l'hexagone et
l'outre-mer mériteront d'être un peu
spécialisé donc le chef est un majeur
des armées il travaille
coordination avec les forces de sécurité
intérieure
toujours une opération qu'on appelle
sentinelle qui est en cours quand c'est
pas sentinelle en Guyane harpie on est
sur le territoire national mais on a
quand même un engagement des forces qui
est parfois très difficile très dur pour
nos militaires déployer sur le terrain
donc là il est clair que peut-être que
plus qu'à la coutumée et vous qui
connaissez bien les armées pour y avoir
servi on va sûrement aussi développer
une approche plus fine géographiquement
en fonction des missions typiquement cet
été feu de forêt déclenchement des
missions de protection du territoire par
le génie etc on avait un savoir-faire
dans les départements du sud de la
France manque de bol réchauffement
climatique ce sont des départements plus
à l'ouest ou plus au nord qui ont été
touchés comment on organise cette
affaire là bon c'est là où l'intran
réserve est réserviste évidemment va
intervenir et là je vais mobiliser dès
demain parce que je recevrai à Balard
les les grands chefs du ministère des
armées je vais beaucoup mobiliser les
DMD et les généraux de zone de défense
pour aussi nous faire remonter un
certain nombre de proposition en lien
mais je ne suis pas objectif sur le
sujet avec nos gendarmes parce que ils
sont militaires ils sont sous l'autorité
du ministre de l'intérieur on sait très
bien aussi que dans certaines
configurations les gendarmes ont des
missions aussi de défense du territoire
donc là le sujet est vaste mais il
faudra qu'on le traite aussi très
correctement dans le rapport à un excès
de la LPM parce qu'il va donner aussi le
chant des ambitions merci monsieur le
ministre et bravo d'avoir relevé avec
brio et panache le défi des réponses en
temps réel aux orateurs de groupe mes
chers collègues prochaines audition
demain à 9h avec le chef d'état-major de
l'armée de l'Air et de l'Espace très
bonne soirée à tous